vivez comprenez en direct les parties
des meilleurs joueurs de la planète avec
les commentaires en français de nos
experts notre moteur d'analyse
l'explorateur d'ouverture et les tables
bases retrouvez toutes les infos
essentielles comme le programme les
horaires des rondes les prix les
résultats les comptes-rendus quotidien
les bio des joueurs les règles des
partages et plus encore vous pouvez même
participer à la compétition en
pronostiquant les résultats pour tenter
de gagner des abonnements premium alors
rendez-vous dès maintenant sur
chess.com/avent ou c'est bien sur le
site internet que sur nos applications
iOS et Android pour vivre votre passion
comme nulle part ailleurs
[Musique]
allô allô ah ça y est bonjour à tous
j'espère que vous allez bien vous êtes
toujours un point de micro dès que je
lance le stream c'est incroyable à
chaque scène à chaque fois que je suis
là et ben j'ai un problème de sel mais
on est là alors bonjour à tous bienvenue
pour les 8e de finale de ce speed Chase
champion chips
on voit que le titre n'a pas été changé
sur twitch malheureusement j'ai pas la
main dessus je ne peux je ne peux pas
trop y faire grand-chose
et donc de mon côté tout va bien alors
le match va commencer normalement
ben dans une minute en tout cas ça
devait commencer
ça devait commencer à 15h donc je pense
que les parties vont arriver alors là
vous voyez ma caméra de dos ne vous
inquiétez pas il arrive
il arrive en fait il y avait un petit
souci vous savez que que
il stream en même temps et il est je
crois qu'il voulait pas mettre sa caméra
sur enfin il voulait pas rentrer dans le
dans le zoom
et du coup voilà c'est bon là et du coup
et ben ils font des copies pour le
mettre dans le jeu quand même bref c'est
c'est toute une histoire
menaca ne voulait pas rentrer dans le
zoom alors tu vas savoir pourquoi il est
un peu capricieux
mais en tout cas on a réussi à choper
quand même sa caméra sa tête donc
rapidement je vous rappelle un petit peu
les règles un petit peu du tournoi donc
en fait c'est un tournoi je vais vous
montrer un petit peu le bracket qu'on a
ici c'est un tournoi à l'élimination
directe cette fois-ci une seule
élimination c'est pas comme comme dans
le club intesto où il y avait deux
éliminations pour des gagnants pour le
départ dans rien à voir là c'est juste
un tournoi par élimination direct donc
c'est des matchs qui durent 3 heures
donc 1h30 de 5 + 1 ensuite on aura une
heure de trois plus une
puis une demi-heure de une plus une donc
trois cadences différentes trois timers
différents et on voit un peu les joueurs
vous avez de Nakamura aujourd'hui
contrôle
mais
you c'est c'est quand même un jour à
plus de 200700 30 40 c'est quand même un
joueur très costaud carwana a besoin
contre Sarana mvl contre gouttesh on va
voir Carl scène contre vidite digne rien
de contre irigasi fille rousse Jacques
contrat
rognan donc le titre on va essayer de le
changer très très vite malheureusement
tu sais que j'ai pas la main dessus je
ne peux pas le changer mais ça va venir
ça va venir très vite
dans quelques instants vous inquiétez
pas le titre va être changé donc il y a
aucun souci là-dessus on est bien dans
le speechestreenship on n'est plus dans
le la revanche d'Ali resa c'est terminé
c'est fini hier d'ailleurs c'était un
beau combat d'ailleurs donc pour ceux
qui ne l'ont pas vu et ben on a les
rediff qui sont disponibles sur Youtube
donc d'aller les voir en tout cas c'est
un beau spectacle hier
j'ai vu j'ai vu Messenger on a vu qu'une
attente
va arriver va essayer de changer et ça
devrait maintenant être bon j'ai eu le
alors si on actualise la page
et ben le titre
actuel de changer alors chez moi
toujours pas mais
mais bref c'est pas le plus le plus
grave le plus important c'est quand même
qu'on puisse suivre ce match
salut bar noir salut à toi j'espère que
tu vas très bien
et tu sais bah écoute
on va changer on va changer ça va
arriver t'inquiète pas
le slack qui sonne derrière ah c'est
parce que j'avais désolé j'entends pas
moi parce que je l'avais j'avais les
écouteurs qui débranchés et je n'avais
pas mis donc je vais enlever le son de
slack
je pense que ça va être faisable je sais
pas comment faire mais
j'imagine qu'il y a moyen d'enlever le
son
[Musique]
j'ai pu regarder ouvert quand même des
fois il y a des informations
importantes je vais enlever dans le
dans le
mélangeur d'audio là
je vais enlever ça
même si il me propose pas
alors ça devait être
le réfressiner effectivement en tout cas
moi j'ai été informé ça mais finalement
écoutez finalement c'est moi qui suis là
et maquette commence par A3 ça commence
alors à cela déjà c'est clair Naka il
veut trop là je vous rappelle Naka il
est il est vraiment c'est vraiment un
tournoi qui lui va comme un gant les
cadences Blitz c'est rapide c'est
extrêmement
extrêmement bien pour lui c'est rends
les carences dans laquelle il excelle et
donc à Cannes vous savez c'est un joueur
qui non seulement est extrêmement fort
mais en plus de ça il adore troll et
donc il commence par A3 au premier coup
et va essayer je pense
pas être du milieu l'adversaire mais
l'idée un peu de de dégoûter
l'adversaire c'est un peu ce qu'il fait
il joue hyper vite hyper bien et en plus
et bien il a un style assez comment on
dit
je peux vous le dire pour avoir jeu
contre lui de nombreuses et nombreuses
parties Nakamura il est extrêmement dur
à jouer psychologiquement c'est très
très dur donc
le match a commencé c'est la ronde 1
enfin la première partie donc en fait
j'ai parti vont
s'enchaîner les unes après les autres
et
donc le titre il faut le changer je sais
bien il y a un bug les les personnes
sont dessus sont en train d'essayer de
changer il y a un bug de twitch à ce
niveau là mais moi j'ai pas la main
dessus je peux rien faire mais ça va ça
va changer en tout cas ne vous inquiétez
pas ce qui est important c'est le
contenu et non pas le titre c'est
vraiment pas ce qui est le plus
important donc n'a qu'à au final ça
transpose une sorte de
d'anglaise ce qu'il a fait un système
avec C4 vous savez et donc le A3 qu'il a
fait au début c'était surtout trop
honneur mais au final il fait quand même
réussi à obtenir
une ouverture
assez assez normal
donc avaler prendrait ça il faut prendre
S5 B5 donc il va empêcher le pion
d'avancer en C6 ou en C5 sur une poussée
6 ou c'est 5 et ben on aurait la prise
en passant donc tours
intéressants en tout cas jouer par
youngui
cavalidité 4 il veut aller sur la case
C6 vous voyez que que Hikaru il avait
vraiment à l'aise il est là il stream il
mange enfin il boit son petit smoothie
en plus
et donc il est vraiment décontracté
merci Mr wesh je sais très bien ça fait
depuis tout à l'heure que il y a un bug
sur twitch mais qui travaille changer je
pense qu'on va ping un message parce que
tu es au moins la dixième personne qui
dit que le petit truc changé et je le
sais bien
et le casque est autorisé parce qu'il
stream en fait il stream donc
le string autorisé pendant ce tournoi
donc du coup le bail voilà mais vous
inquiétez pas que tout est contrôlé
c'est-à-dire qu'en fait il a
stream il a son écran qui est partagé
aussi avec les arbitres
il y a aussi une caméra derrière lui
enfin il y a vraiment tout qui fait pour
être bien
il y a aucun moyen de pouvoir de pouvoir
de pouvoir tricher il a pas le chat je
crois qu'il a le chat en émoticône
obligatoire pour pas qu'on puisse lui
écrire ou voir des choses alors il n'est
pas sur tweet mais vous savez qu'en ce
moment on a qu'à il stream sur notre
plateforme que twitch donc c'est pour ça
qu'il n'est pas gentille et quelqu'un
lui l'écout dans le casque mais c'est
pas possible parce qu'il est pas encore
et il est en train de stream il est en
train de stream et en plus comme je vous
l'avais dit et ben les arbitres ont
accès à la à son écran il voit tout son
écran et ils ont aussi accès à comment
ça s'appelle au mélangeur
[Musique]
un truc comme ça
peut-être le patron du nom je crois que
c'est ça
non c'est pas c'est pas ça je suis bête
c'est quoi le nom du truc je sais plus
comment ça s'appelle
il y a un truc bref il y a une autre
devant ah c'est qui alors moi j'ai
rajouté un petit un petit truc mais
ok c'est qui qui
le nom du truc
voilà si vous actualisez la page Youtube
enfin pendant la page twitch excusez-moi
si vous actualisez et ben vous verrez
[Musique]
vous verrez le titre qui a été changé
donc pour ceux qui sont sur
sur
twitch n'hésitez pas à changer juste
écrire un petit truc
à mes amis
technicien
donc c'est un masque qui va durer trois
heures
trois heures donc 1h30 de
5 + 1 vous avez le chrono en haut à
gauche ensuite on a une heure de cinq
plus un puis une demi-heure de
une plus une voilà voilà
l'avantage de la plateforme je sais pas
franchement mais en vrai c'est pas trop
intéresse pour l'instant nous on est sur
twitch on va pas faire la pub à votre
site
c'est pas du tout c'est pas du tout le
but alors j'ai trop été donc là vous
avez vu que
dans une position où en fait et ben les
cases blanches sont vraiment anaca les
Noirs auront du mal à attaquer sur casse
blanche c'est pour ça qu'en fait le roi
est plutôt bien en E2 on peut imaginer
un jour une tour venir en C1 une année
en C4 et vraiment contrôler tout ça donc
j'ai aussi peur de damage 3 qui pourrait
un jour être une menace si jamais la
tour partait
alors tour des 6
dames et il a fait le plan que j'avais
proposé attention à une anguille qui
commence à être un petit peu mal au
temps vous savez dans ces positions dans
ces matchs contre Nakamura il faut
vraiment essayer de jouer vite et pas
et pas se faire avoir la taille il est
vraiment incroyable il est il est un peu
insupportable quand il joue parce qu'il
voit tout il est trop fort il est très
rapide et c'est vraiment difficile de
les prendre des points donc dame 7
et en plus accélère et plus les
redoutable c'est pour ça qu'il faut pas
être en directeur contre lui il faut
essayer de de garder un peu de temps je
pense
et puis la position est quand même pas
mal pour pour les Noirs ici maintenant
on l'avantage on a un gros sens solide
et puis au final les blancs on sait pas
trop ce qu'ils font attends je pensais à
une idée avec dammeka pour jouer 4 et
essayer de prendre un peu plus les cases
blanches
mais
sur dame G4
6 juste d'arbre rouge
qui va essayer de tourner les pièces
tourner et tourner et tourner pour
essayer de de
gagner un peu de temps à la pendule et
puis plus le temps passe plus du
yanglier sera mal au temps et vous savez
de nacasse
c'est c'est un joueur bon il est
extrêmement fort d'échec mais c'est un
genre qui adore aussi jouer le temps il
adore flag il adore ce jeu un petit peu
un peu crados et du coup je pense qu'une
stratégie clairement dans une position
c'est de tourner les pièces attendre et
flag
et je te vois ça y est parfait c'est bon
nickel merci
c'est bon on a réparé tous les soucis
qu'il y avait alors au démarrage il y
avait des petits soucis il y avait un
bug moi j'avais mon micro qui marchait
pas enfin qui se met jamais à jour à
chaque fois que je mets une nouvelle
truc au micro-idée pas là il y avait
aussi un problème sur twitch et sur
Youtube c'est incroyable aujourd'hui
alors il y a un écart mais il y a un
écart vous savez pourquoi il y en a
qu'un parce que en fait normalement
pour ceux qui suivent l'événement et ben
il y a un écart de 15 secondes en fait
moi je suis la partie depuis
[Musique]
la catégorie event sur cheesecom et donc
du coup il y a un écart de 15 secondes
qui est fait automatiquement si je
suivais la partie depuis le live de
classecom je devrais mettre sur Obs à un
écart de de 15 secondes mais comme il
garde le stream je pense qu'il n'est pas
de il a pas mis je pense de
de différence c'est pour ça qu'il y a
pas de trucs mais en vrai bon c'est pas
très très important
donc H5 a été joué
par maca et regarder la différence de
temps 55 secondes à 25 et cette
différence de temps qui va peut-être
faire la différence entre dans la partie
donc assez avec des jouets il y a
presque tout con mais si ce qui peut
être un jour une idée avec puis on prend
ses 7 et à la dame donc ça marchera pas
pour l'instant mais attention si le
câble est venait à partir et ben ça
pourrait marcher pendant cavalier G8
j'aurais peut-être tout reprendre et le
point qui pousse ça pourrait marcher
OK
de nouveau avec l'avion en DS c'est
plutôt une bonne case alors faut F5
comment est-ce qu'on joue là j'ai même
alors faut prendre je sais pas
ouais étant des 5 je pensais ouais il
fait mon coup
et maintenant ramener le roi via E4 ça
pourrait être une bonne idée Naka qui
joue tous mes coups
il veut être sûr de gagner il va être
sur gagner il joue comme je touche
en dessin que c'est plutôt une une bonne
idée je pense
le roi actif vous savez
à chaque fois et finalement les noirs
qui arrivent à pas mal ce faire ce pion
j'ai un peu peur de ce pion après un
tour C5 3D 6 regardez
depuis on sait ce qui peut tomber
essayer de pousser se faire un pion un
pion passé
F5 qui a été joué préhistoire prend et
la tour qui va rentrer en G6 et en G7 là
c'est bon c'est trop difficile pour Yuri
qui a failli perdre autant
pour qu'il arrive donc il va reculer le
pion qui pousse mais dans les blancs qui
ont une position assez écrasante le pion
qui va tomber et Nakamura qui gagne
cette partie ok 1-0 pour Naka il est
content il commence à danser ça y est je
vais tourner l'échiquier vous savez que
tu es parti
s'enchaînent très très vite donc là
pendant 1h30 en fait il y aura pas de
pause il y aura pas de pause qu'on a une
heure et demie je crois qu'il y a une
pause au milieu de chaque
portion de jeu c'est à dire qu'il y aura
une pause normalement
après 45 minutes mais je suis pas sûr à
100% on va le vérifier tout à l'heure
mais sinon il n'y a pas de pause les
parties s'enchaînent s'enchaînent
s'enchaînent et puis c'est pas comme
hier ou à chaque partie il fallait il
fallait faire un truc alors je vous
enlever un petit peu ce petit truc là
c'est un petit peu moche qui va
elle vous enlevez aussi votre petit
verre ici
voilà on sera mieux comme ça
alors donc ça c'est une espagnole
symétrique
salut
Bundy fr
salut à tous pour ceux qui arrivent tous
ceux qui nous regardent depuis cheesecom
depuis twitch YouTube depuis
toutes ces plateformes en tout cas
bonjour à toutes n'hésitez pas à nous
follow pour ceux qui sont là
c'est gratuit le follow et ça vous
permet de vous tenir informé de tout ce
qu'on fait sur cheesecom soit des vidéos
des shorts que ce soit des live que ce
soit plein de choses n'hésitez pas
vraiment à nous follow vous serez au
courant de tout ce qui se passe dans le
milieu alors à 5 a été joué par NACA
donc il prend un peu de l'espace de ce
côté là B5 reste en bas et Dame des deux
trois D1 bon c'est truc assez assez
typique vous savez qu'au début on sort
les pièces donc les cavaliers les fous
on prend le centre avec les pions et on
met les tours au centre ou sur les
colonnes ouvertes donc une colonne
ouvert c'est une colle il y a pas de
pion
mais s'il y a pas de colonie verte
c'est-à-dire que c'est tous les pions
sont encore ici et ben généralement on
met les pièces vers le centre parce que
c'est au milieu dans le centre que la
pollution va s'ouvrir et que les tours
seront possiblement fortes des 5 5 coups
ici
de vous donner je perd un pion après la
prise en dessin que je pensais que
j'avais peut-être défendait j'ai mal vu
il faut prendre à deux c'est vraiment un
coup qu'on peut regarder et écouter
Hikaru c'est un joueur qui qui est très
gourmand il adore les petits plots comme
ça et si ils vont rien ne concret je
vous garantis qu'il va manger depuis un
deux ensuite il y a faut prendre H6 qui
est une menace quand même donc si tu
prends à deux faut prendre un H6 alors
quand même assez fort par exemple puis
on prend et d'un prank ça a l'air quand
même extrêmement difficile il y a pas de
moyens de parer le mat donc
je pense qu'ici qui va pas manger depuis
1 2 mais
elle réfléchit il calcule en regardant
en l'air
mais je pense que il a pas envie de
manger H6 enfin de manger à deux parce
que ça pose pas trop de problèmes donc
il va faire quelque chose de différent
c'est que la menace de mangeage 6 elle
est quand même assez forte
donc pour l'instant si tu vois là je
sais c'est toujours faut prendre
peut-être un intermédiaire à un moment
donné
donc oui alors ma caille
c'est pour ça qu'il parle
il est bavard il stream et je pense que
Naka il est jamais
il est jamais aussi dangereux que quand
il se trime parce que je pense que le
fait d'être suivi par des milliers de
personnes et ben ça lui procure une une
assurance et quelque chose il a vraiment
envie de bien faire et et j'ai
l'impression quand il stream il est
encore plus fort que quand tu sais le
pas et et pourtant il est déjà
monstrueux bref
donc ouais non il est pas sur twitch il
stream sur une autre plateforme qui
s'appelle kick Billy mais t'inquiète pas
qu'il stream
en tout cas il se streamait pas ça
serait un gros de personnage là
d'ailleurs regardez j'ai une nouvelle
j'ai une nouvelle comment dire scène je
voulais montrer est-ce que vous préférez
cette scène là où on voit les joueurs on
voit moi on voit aussi
le format des partages enfin il y a un
truc qui est qui est en boucle avec les
cadence tout ça où est-ce qu'on préférez
celle là
et en fait ce qui se passe c'est ici
vous avez
la prédiction de la partie d'avant sauf
que là c'est pas mis à jour
malheureusement parce que
la prédiction de yongli à 4%, ça va être
possible
impossible même si je suis pas il fait
pas 4 %, c'est n'importe quoi c'est le
siège non ok c'est cheaté par contre
j'ai aussi d'autres si vous voulez
d'autres scènes dites moi j'essaye
d'accord je sais plein de choses vous me
dites ce que vous préférez est-ce que
celle là elle vous bon c'est mal cadré
faudrait que je le recadrer mieux mais
est-ce que cette scène elle vous plaît
ou est-ce que
où est-ce que c'est pourri
qu'est-ce que vous préférez en fait je
regarde la carte
bien
est-ce que vous préférez celle-là ou
est-ce que vous préférez l'autre
carreau le plus petit possible
la première sondage
comme vous voulez en fait c'est juste
pour changer un peu
la mienne à la place des carreaux
pourquoi pas ok ok bon je vois que je
suis un élément
obligatoire pour ce stream donc je vais
mettre ma tête
d'ailleurs le score il n'est pas mis à
jour je pensais que c'était automatique
par cheesecom je vais du coup mettre à
jour
les points je suis désolé à plat donc
1-0 pour Yao dans ce match
donc voilà donc du coup il s'est passé
plein de choses pendant que on testait
les scènes et il faut prendre F5 qui
donne la part de fou c'est ça que j'aime
pas donner la part de fou et ici faut
prendre H6 puis on prend un H6 et puis
on prend le 5 alors l'idée intéressante
c'est qu'après prise
d'un point H6 qui attaque à la fois là
et à la fois sans ce qui
force dans le 7 G4 et là je menace j'ai
5 suivi de F6
et ça a l'air mat un peu de partout ça a
l'air hyper intéressant E4 avec les
jouets G5 et cavalier 8 en H7 donc là il
y a eu la prise en H6 apparemment
c'était pas le meilleur coup on voit le
la jauge qui descend un petit peu et
après l'échange des pièces et plein de
cavaliers 5 j'ai l'impression ici que
les blancs sont quand même pas mal ce
pion qui va tomber
et ça va faire deux pions de plus pour
pour les blancs avec bien sûr il faut
toujours poser mais en tout cas c'est
c'est intéressant
alors je vais voir si la caméra je peux
la centrer je pense qu'elle est déjà
rentré chez moi mais je vais essayer
quand même remonter un peu c'est la
caméra mais je pense que chez moi elle
est max
je sais pas je peux un peu remonter je
peux un peu remonter
j'essaye
OK
je suis max
je peux pas faire plus au niveau de You
qui a qui a la caméra
là je l'ai mis le plus bas possible
donc écoutez
tourner 8 on va manger manger manger
ils aiment bien montrer leur fronts
ça a l'air pas mal du tout sur cavalier
prend à manger tu as du fou pour
attaquer le pion C6
et pour voir si j'ai pas tordu avec des
idées de manger des pions ici et aussi
tous les sites qui peut mettre la
pression sur le pion F2 ça a l'air quand
même
du jeu adversaire cavalier roi et F1 et
surtout les deux il veut tout ou deux
c'est pour ça qu'il a fait royal pour
défendre en avance la case 2 et il se
dit que si on échange échange échange
échange dans ce plan il sera mangé il y
aura plutôt il y aura plus de jeu et les
blancs pourront gagner tranquillement la
partie
donc croyez fin a été joué
Magnus a gagné hier gros match
c'est un supermarché
en vrai
Armageddon dans le premier set
mais grosse spectacle en tout cas gros
spectacle la parfum le matériel une
promotion cavalier dans les raisins
juste fantastique
très bon match
donc pour ceux qui n'ont pas vu
d'ailleurs ce match et ben écoute
disponible en transmission sur sur
Youtube c'est comme fr
vous avez toutes les journées à toutes
les rondes tout a été retransmis dans la
division 1 on va d'ailleurs aussi
couvert la division avec avec Laurent
Freyssinet on a un petit peu couvert
aussi avec une nappe est une Bagot
donc il y a vraiment beaucoup de choses
à voir si vous voulez
aller voir donc ici la manger ici la
palette autour ou deux avant et là à
trois était donc un son pion prend si on
prend le pion est pas arrêtable ça s'en
fout un gars et je pourrai plus
rattraper le pion donc cavalier prend
et cette position malhere de de sentir
un peu la nul donc bien sûr il y a deux
pions d'avance pour les blancs mais
c'est des pions doublé ici ça peut être
en prise et si je prends là puis on
prend bah tu vas manger là après je
défends ici mais tu passeras pas je
pense que il y a très très grosse chance
de nul dans cette partie manger manger
là ça c'est nul direct ça va pas jouer
je pense
à moins que vous êtes quand même bien
jouer pendant très longtemps c'est
finalement pourquoi parce qu'en fait il
aime bien troll et un peu énervé
l'adversaire il aime bien aussi gagner
du temps à la pendule là pour l'instant
il mène au score donc cette partie qui
devrait se terminer maintenant et faire
nul maintenant et Ben et ben il aimerait
bien enfin il a bien des fois faire
durer la partie pour gagner du temps je
vous rappelle qu'un chronomètre en haut
à gauche qui reste 166 minutes dans
cette portion de temps et les heures
aiment bien généralement j'aurais très
longtemps juste pour
pour comment dire gagner du temps et
puis énerver un peu l'adversaire les
blancs je joue ici mais les blancs ici
dans une malheureusement parce que là
c'est bloqué là c'est bloqué et là c'est
bloqué en fait
c'est nul c'est nul direct
mais je pense que la cave à la jouer un
petit peu juste pour énervation mais en
tout cas une anguille c'est très bien
comment il a qu'à c'est très bien que
Naka il était comme ça il va laisser
partir pendant 5 minutes
ça va mieux et puis voilà ensuite Naka
elle est noire c'est le petit problème
alors je dis que c'est un problème parce
que
vous savez que la règle des 50 coups
s'en prise ni mouvement de pions et ben
ça va s'arrêter bientôt et n'akai pourra
pas bouger le pion
il pourrait vous faire un béton un jour
et sur il faut qu'on met trois bah on
commence parce qu'au final ce pion on a
on s'en fout il sert à rien
et
ok bon ça va faire nul en tout cas
la tenté le petit piège de marlou mais
ce pion servait à rien de toute façon
donc là on a encore une fois 50 coups
j'ai plein de pions de plus avec les
blancs mais je peux rien y faire
il pousse le purge voilà
ses pions sont bloqués
et on peut plus rien faire
plus rien faire en tout cas il s'amuse
bien il là ils sont à 100 coups
et mais bon je l'avais dit Naka il aime
bien continuer c'est c'est position
et je pense 80 un bon client parce que
moi je verrais bien yanguy faire un
petit peu H6 juste pour troll à son tour
tiens mange tu on refait 50 coups si tu
veux moi je pense que ça va se passer
comme ça
en tout cas c'est possible
il s'éclate deux jours s'amusent bien
les deux joueurs s'amusent bien
et
[Musique]
est-ce que c'est pour avoir du temps en
cinq minutes non mais c'est pareil en
fait
là vous avez encore 63 minutes
de 5 + une
et donc bon ben ils font passer le temps
là ça fait quand même trois minutes qui
sont dans cette finale là donc en 3
minutes il a quasiment épuisé la moitié
du temps d'une partie donc écoutez
en fait
dans ce match là je pense qu'on a
camoura il a absolument zéro chance de
perdre il est trop fort il est trop une
différence de niveau entre des devoirs
et
d'ailleurs après si vous pourra parler
un petit peu des prédictions qui ont été
données
par técom mais
en fait
comment dire
je pense que la cadence dans laquelle il
est moins fort par exemple il peut plus
se faire avoir contre Yorki sembler 105
+ 1 parce que nous c'est vraiment pas un
manche et je voudrais bien par contre je
pense que plus la cadence ça s'accélère
plus maca il va être monstrueux donc
dans la stratégie
[Musique]
mais bon c'est un peu ça a pas de sens
pour moi allez ça recommencer
ah oui bah tiens l'histoire wesh je te
la fais direct après prédiction d'hier
je suis désolé j'avais oublié donc qui a
gagné déjà hier et qui c'est
un petit doute
j'ai un petit doute ça y est j'ai payé
vos dettes et est-ce que vous voulez
qu'on fasse une petite prédiction pour
ce match alors je pense que si on fait
une prédiction mais qui gagne le match
vous allez tous mettre NACA donc ça va
pas le faire donc ce qu'on pourrait
faire une prédiction on pourrait essayer
de prédire le score de you pour être
plus
faire si je vous demande qui va gagner
malgré tout se dire dans le cas
par partie ouais ouais je pourrais après
malheureusement les modaux ils sont pas
là je crois que tout seul aujourd'hui
mais on peut faire un une prédit par 7
moi je pensais on peut prédire le score
de U
il reste une heure il est à un demi
combien pensez-vous que you peut faire
alors je vous propose un score vous avez
même plus ou moins je pense
alors en plus j'avais accès dans D1 je
vais regarder j'avais accès au
prédictions
faites par cheesecom par rapport par
rapport aux joueurs par rapport aussi à
ce qui s'est passé avant vous savez
qu'il y a un historique par rapport à
tous les speechess qui sont passés
et du coup pardon excusez-moi je l'ai
ouvert dans un mauvais lien dans un
mauvais truc
mais
j'ai accès à quelque chose et je crois
que n'a qu'à arrêter de donner un
ah ouais c'est énorme les
prédictions elles sont elles sont
énormes
les prédictions elles sont elles sont
Naka a été a été donné gagnant à 95%
ce qui est énorme mais attendez et sinon
pour le
5 + 1
le score de U a été par test commun a
été posée à deux et demi
ce qui est voilà ça c'est un indice
quand je peux vous donner après ça veut
rien dire ça veut absolument rien dire
mais apparemment il pense que si c'est
demi pour Naka il y aura environ 10
parties donc environ 10 parties vous
avez un peu les infos des bookmakers
maintenant je vais vous mettre une
prédiction dans le chat vous allez me
dire un petit peu
non c'est pas un match à la fois quand
tu
vois que les prédiction du coup et je
vais vous poser la question est-ce que
vous pensez
que une anguille faire plus que
elle a prédit qui va durer deux minutes
je l'ai
moi je peux pas voter j'ai bien compris
allez
stream sur sa plateforme alors j'ai mis
si vous voulez
parier sur le score du 7 juste de you
parce que on aurait pu aussi parler sur
le score de Maka est-ce que vous pensez
que you va faire plus que 2 et demi ou
est-ce qu'il va faire égal ou moins que
deux et demi
donc je vous laisse parier sur le chat
donc ça par contre c'est tout ça c'est
sur sur twitch on peut pas le voir sur
youtube malheureusement mais là il y a
une partie où au un bel avantage il y a
déjà
0,5 pour you
[Musique]
alors donc d'un B3
d'un
qui a commencé avec A4 cette partie et
j'avais même pas regardé les gars
j'avais même pas vu le début de partie
Naka qui troll complètement avec les
Blancs complètement et il veut avoir son
adversaire un peu à l'usure il veut le
rendre fou
ils veulent rendre fou
donc d'un B3
c'est simple donc comment est-ce qu'on
joue maintenant il y a un gros problème
avec il est très malin il est très mal
dessine un cas il devrait ouais
franchement il mérite de se faire punir
il mérite de se faire punir
dans ce match
il mérite tellement de se faire punir
si vous voulez parier les gars là je
vois qu'il y en a pas beaucoup qui ont
misé sur égal ou moins que deux et demi
et franchement
il y a un gros facteur à prendre un
compact à la France quand je vois quand
je vois quasiment 85 sur plus que 2 et
demi et seulement 5 cas dans les moins
de 1 et demi la côte elle est quand même
pas mal
vous savez Naka il est quand même
redoutable dans ces portions après mais
c'est pas un manche
mais voilà on verra en tout cas
[Musique]
donc le 3 a été joué en plus la caille
un truc qui est horrible avec lui c'est
que
bon très souvent il y a des poubelles
parce qu'il joue à cadres ou B4 il fait
un peu n'importe quoi pour l'ouverture
pour troll l'adversaire et Mylène
capacité à défendre ses poubelles qui
est assez monstrueux et franchement n'a
qu'à pour gagner une partie contre lui
il faut le battre plusieurs fois par la
même partie c'est
c'est assez incroyable genre tu dormais
une il se relève et à chaque fois chaque
partie se relève et
il faut vraiment il faut vraiment le
mettre KO quoi et c'est difficile quoi
et en fait la prend vachement d'énergie
parce que tu peux le battre plusieurs
fois mais sur un match dure trois heures
chaque partie ça demande une énergie ouf
de le battre
alors c'est vraiment dur quoi et donc
c'est pas pour rien que d'un cas c'est
un des meilleurs joueurs du monde en
plus de thérapie d'ailleurs dans ce
format là et dans ce dans cette
compétition Naka a quasiment tout le
temps gagnant j'avais vu un petit peu
les stats je crois que Magnus avait
gagné en 2016 et en 2017 et à partir de
2018 je crois que Naka a gagné toutes
les éditions
en tout cas c'est ce que j'avais vu
jusqu'à au moins 2021 après je sais plus
ce que ce que disait la suite mais
mais
[Musique]
il y a un truc comme ça il faudrait
regarder là j'ai pas exactement les les
j'ai pas exactement les rêves
F4 a été joué par par Maga ça donne un
tas de cases mais ça menace F5
encore une fois de ma carte de coupe
bizarre mais il faut punir ok j'ai trois
Tour Eiffel 2 prises
pour ceux qui ont parié pour moins de
2h30 il faut espérer que la carte
enchaîne toute la victoire pour ceux qui
ont parié plus de Demi et ben il faut
respecter
bien parti de la perdre il n'est pas
favori dans ce match dans cette partie
il est pas favoris il y a quand même une
sacrée poubelle les blancs d'une
position tellement
pendant les Noirs d'une position
tellement tranquille
après attention et aussi ça en prison
pour voir un petit peu
comme cavalier F5 serait intéressant
parce que je menace de manger ici et en
plus faire qu'elle prend le 3 par
exemple c'est un coup qui se regarde
après dans le 4 ok c'est une belle case
la case de 4 mais bon pour les questions
on sent juste
très très dur pour pour un gars qui a
des pièces complètement
juste ma place
[Musique]
car elle prend G4 toujours 3 G1 et tu me
dis que tu as sans prise et sans prise
en tête c'est possible encore une fois
qui essaye de faire douter l'adversaire
voyez un cavalier 4 échecs
en prison
peut-être il y a une défense on sait pas
mais il s'est vraiment de rendre fou
l'adversaire donc là il va réfléchir 20
secondes pour deux fois le 7 voilà et
l'agriculture a attendu et il fait donc
il fait toute l'adversaire regardez car
les projets je fais ça après je me
laisse des 5 puis on passe les protéger
cavalier en prison de 4 et il a donné la
tour bon là il est quand même très mal
j'avais pas vu qu'il y avait longtemps
emprise
là il est quand même pas bien du tout
Naka cette partie ça serait une très
grande surprise quand même s'il ne la
perdait pas comment il peut ne pas la
perdre en fait je me laisse tout
reprendre
la tour
il y a beaucoup trop de choses ça va pas
du tout pour Nakamura
dans cette partie d'un F3 était joué
prise il y a le pion C4 qui va tomber
aussi à tour qui va rentrer
à F6 un jour et le fou qui pourra
ressortir voilà
il sort le fou il peut bouger la tour
aussi tout le monde va ressortir
et bah c'est juste complètement perdu
un son gardé pour chess com alors donc
j'ai trois forcer là je peux tout
échanger et manger là c'est fini
après je sais pas comment ça se passe
dans le ciel bleu mais
alors tout reprend pourquoi il a pas
mangé là aussi
ça va
[Musique]
autant alors qu'apparemment la jauge
peut-être que tout roue 3 gagne la
partie
et ouais tu prends là je prends un
chèque et je prends la tour
et bah si tu bouges la tour
ben je fais ça et je fais ça ou ça
incroyable qui perd autant alors qu'il
avait réussi à retourner
la partie incroyable
incroyable allez on a maintenant
avec ses coups hein regardez il
recommence il leur demande ils ont
encore à 5 dans le début de partie
ils ont encore à 5 alors je vais vous
mettre le score à jour
le score à jour
on est à 1,5
victoire à une victoire de you pour
pour changer un petit peu à cette
prédiction alors c'est la prédiction
elle est perdue je pense qu'on pourra en
faire une dans le même set mais on est à
1,5
[Musique]
oui je sais mais s'il y a marqué pts
chez moi je me fais taper sur les doigts
si c'est pas fait à 100%
donc
il faut tout faire
tu auras 8
c'est vrai qu'en bas le score il est
il est marqué aussi
alors
je pense que je pense que à 5 c'est
encore plus c'est encore plus troll
que assise B5 c'est moins nul que à 5
ans
et il fait il fait à 4 avec les Blancs à
5 avec une main bon bah écoute
il stream sur ouais
en fait il troll complètement il s'en
fout complet
il veut jouer que des ouvertures de type
A4 pour le rendre fou
et
le démolir un petit peu mentalement vous
voyez que là il y a un et demi
et la cage on voit que des trucs avec A4
A5 au premier coup mais après il arrive
quand même à retomber dans des positions
qui sont à peu près normal vous voyez il
fait à 4 enfin il fait à 5 6
et après de 44 vous voyez au final en
fait c'est pas si grave que ça quoi ça
reste pas bien sûr mais c'est il y a
pire quoi il y a pire salut Francky
c'est à toi j'espère que tu vas bien
une drogue oui il y a moyen qu'il en
moine grave
F5 avec les noirs
donc là on va continuer avec la dame en
même temps que j'aime bien
bienvenue à toi
mais si tous
un gros problème sur le pion sur le pion
aussi donc on va doubler les tours ici
et je pense qu'il veut mettre le
cavalier je pensais qu'il aurait voulu
faire
des Noirs sont quand même bien ficelés
là
bien ficelé
un paresseux j'aurais pu faire
malheureusement je préfère qu'une
prédiction à la fois
ça va être cool que je puisse faire
plein de prédictions en parallèle sur
twitch pour pouvoir
avoir plein de Paris de partout mais là
du coup j'ai un pari en cours déjà il y
a il y a une prédiction en cours je peux
pas changer tous les trucs c'est c'est
pas évident
des moyens plus agressifs
il y a sûrement moyen d'exploiter le à
cinq C6 de la carte ça c'est clair mais
bon là on est en blitz et puis
je pense que yoongi il avait deux échecs
aussi
pas analysé à 5 quand même
salut Yume
comment va-t-il
chercher un modo pour pouvoir faire
plein de prédictions
j'en ai fait une là actuellement je
viens de proposer
à demander est-ce que vous pensez que va
faire plus que deux et demi dans ce set
et pour l'instant et ben il y a un et
demi à une nuit donc ça se passe pas mal
pour you malgré le fait que Nakamura il
joue que des trucs complètement tordus
il joue à 4 avec le blanc en premier
coup à 5 avec les Noirs voilà c'est
plein de trucs pas bon du tout pour
troll l'adversaire complètement mais
vous inquiétez pas que quand tu vas
finir par se faire battre dans chaque
partie et ben il risque de changer quand
même de jouer d'accord
parce que là voilà quoi
ah oui il est très concentré
il sait comment il a qu'à
et il sait que par enfant dans son jeu
et que ta taille est terrible
extrêmement fort et que s'il veut gagner
il faut être sérieux bref voilà puis en
plus c'est pas le genre de la maison de
you de troll des joueurs c'est pas le
genre d'être malpoli de backlin party
bref c'est un joueur très sérieux et que
peu importe le score peu importe tout ça
je pense qu'il va continuer à être
sérieux et à y croire
j'ai 5 a été joué par maca alors ma Casa
qui part
complètement leur prise prise il veut
tout âge 6 il veut attaquer sur la
colonne h probablement
qui est le plus fort
c'est une très bonne question à dire
c'est une très bonne question
alors j'ai 5 écoutez ça a l'air pas mal
ce coup j'ai 5 ans il n'aime pas du tout
mais moi je trouve que c'est c'est un
coup qui pose des questions alors bien
sur Stallone plein de cases mais d'un
autre côté
ça évite
je pense que ça arrive ça peut arriver
vite hein pour pour le noir en tout cas
pas c'est clair salut Arnaud
j'espère que tu vas bien Arnaud Arnaud
Paris
la barre tout à l'heure le G5
mais après la prise elle aime bien
finalement
mais qui va se faire ban par le modo de
twitch pour mettre que des majuscules
c'est que ça arrive à plus d'un quand
même de se faire de se faire ban
a été joué
tu as le droit toi
j'ai envie de j'ai envie de
j'ai envie de te battre juste pour juste
pour
[Musique]
ah mais je suis modo comme toi c'est pas
ma chaîne ok dommage j'ai essayé de te
battre
[Musique]
j'ai essayé de te battre mais c'est vrai
que c'est pas ma chaîne
d'ailleurs il joue premier match contre
qui joue déjà
il joue Eric Asie il me semble de
mémoire pour vérifier après mais juste
en noir
salut
à toi
et je commence de plus en plus à aimer
la position de maca ici
Naka qui qui
[Musique]
a une position dans quel pion aussi ce
qui me faiblesse mais il y a une
colonache potentiellement qui peut être
très forte
un jour avant qu'elle soit
n'est pas loin de champion du monde
Arnaud
pas loin du monde ça se joue à un jour
dame
non mais en fait il y a il y a un bot
s de tag il y a un bots
si tu fais des messages avec trop trop
de majuscules c'est un truc automatique
et du coup depuis qu'on faisait la bonne
chaise tour ces derniers jours il y a
plusieurs personnes qui sont fait ban
parce qu'ils mettaient plein de
majuscules et c'était pas nous c'était
juste le bot quoi comme il est modo et
en plus il met des majuscules je me dis
tiens ça va être marrant qu'il se fasse
autoban par votre bottes mais
malheureusement c'est pas le cas ça
aurait été drôle juste mais je crois que
c'est pas le cas
il parle il streamer si c'est les stream
sur un autre plateforme mais
je pense qu'il a raison de vouloir un
peu changer la dame parce que il y a une
pression que peuvent arriver vite sur la
colonnage et il a peur Naka il veut
garder les dames parce qu'il veut garder
tout ça regardez le photographes 8 F4
waouh il veut ramener la dame
[Musique]
et F4 c'est extrêmement bien joué très
marrant il a un jeu quasiment F4
instantanément
comme si j'avais pris mauvais le F4 qui
avait le 7 a été joué
je pense qu'il veut bah il veut juste
[Musique]
j'ai toujours F3 en plus c'est quoi la
rêve sur ça
a l'air quasiment
il y a pas d'échec et c'est maintenant
pas
matinal
il faut que j'ai deux puis on prend
quand même assez mat
allez hop et du coup voilà c'est la
pause donc je vous rappelle que il y a
une pause donc j'avais un doute tout à
l'heure il y a une pause à la moitié de
chaque timer donc là on est arrivé à
moins de 45 minutes qui était la pause
du coup donc
vous pouvez faire une pause je vais
ajuster le score de Hikaru qui vient de
marquer son deuxième point et demi
cent fois pourquoi il y a les
commentaires cheescom sur les coups
pas compris ta question Magic Jess
les commentaires sur les coups on pourra
je commence c'est ça
pourquoi je commente ou j'ai pas compris
il n'y a aucun moyen
[Musique]
quel fou si elle est bleue
ouais non en plus naï il a sûrement dû
en juin à 5 en jouant à 4 il a sûrement
dû regarder un peu un moyen de pas
perdre complètement au bout de trois
coups quoi je pense pas qu'il soit
notamment stupide et ça qui est
qui est assez incroyable
les coups manqués excellents
ah les coups manqué tout ça
oui ça je peux l'enlever
l'événement est sûr que faire
événement sur tout ce qu'on va faire
c'est un événement de choses comme ça
quand une pièce bouge on voit que
justcom met un symbole genre faute ou
manqué ah ok
bah ça si vous voulez
je peux je peux l'enlever si vous
préférez
est-ce que vous préférez que je l'enlève
ou vous voulez le garder
salut
[Musique]
ou je garde moi je l'ai mis mais après
après je peux l'enlever c'est pas du
tout
[Musique]
c'est pas du tout
gênant si je l'enlève
mais
voilà donc deux et demi 1 et demi pour
l'instant pour yolandi donc la prochaine
partie de la cas va avoir les blancs ou
changer la oups me tromper vraiment je
me suis trompé de
[Musique]
scène ça va être celle-là
c'est pas encore cela je suis encore
trompé j'ai trop de sel en fait voilà ça
va être celle-là
et donc il y a une pause voilà donc très
courte apparemment parce que lorsqu'on
est déjà de retour
et
c'est mieux avec
non on s'enchaîne direct mais il y a une
pause au milieu du timer tu avais le
timer c'était 1h30 et donc 45 minutes
c'est la moitié mais pas coupé au menu
de la partie donc il y a une pause
on va dire rapidos entre enfin à chaque
moitié de temps
et je crois qu'il y a une pause plus
grande à la fin de timer
entre les différentes phases de jeu je
crois
on va voir en tout cas
oui je vous ai gardé la barre et tout et
tout ça
oui après c'est même pas là il y a pas
le il y a pas l'ordinateur il y a juste
les coups
bon pas bon ça nous permet de en blitz
je pense quelque chose d'un peu plus on
va dire spectaculaire et il y a beaucoup
moins de de enfin beaucoup moins
commenté et rentrer vraiment dans le
dans le vif du sujet il y a plein de on
peut pas parler vraiment d'échec si
c'est plutôt un tournoi on va dire de
partir lente etc là on pourra vraiment
rentrer beaucoup plus dans tout ce qui
est tout ce qui est variante ouverture
un calcul etc là malheureusement on vu
la rapidité ok ça se passe et ben on
peut pas trop trop commenter tout ça
mais on essaie quand même de faire un
petit peu et c'est pour ça que du coup
laisser les signes n'a l'air pas mal vu
vu la cadence
et il stream sur kick Hikaru oui
d'ailleurs bonjour à Olivier tchez qui
nous regarde depuis YouTube et qui nous
salue
non je peux enlever comme c'est pas un
problème
alors j'ai pas exactement le tableau je
l'avais hier il y a un match aujourd'hui
demain il y a je me demande s'il y a pas
de match demain
et en fait ça va durer plusieurs
semaines
le tournoi
[Musique]
mais
il y en a quasiment
[Musique]
c'est pas le tableau malheureusement
demain il y a un match que je vais
commenter
et il y en a un autre que je commencerai
pas
on tourne un petit peu avec les
différents commentateurs
salut
c'est bien de comparer
stouf et il nous met pas les mettre dans
la même dans la même dans le même sac
alors j'ai pas alors je sais que Kévin
Bordy donc je sais qu'il va stream les
matchs de de
mvl donc du coup demain c'est peut-être
mal de VL je peux pas j'ai pas
malheureusement c'est pas malheureuse
les infos je sais pas si dans le chat on
peut nous le donner je vais essayer de
de demander de la pause
j'avais un tableau que je vais remonter
remonter dans la conversation
c'est pas ça
je vais vous le dire
c'est bon juste le tableau je vais le
garder
alors
mvl il joue il joue contre Google et il
joue le 11 c'est ça
[Musique]
et à lireza il joue le 8
il y a plein de match en fait il y a
plein de matchs
alors est-ce que les parties ont
commencé à ça a commencé j'avais pas vu
à l'instant et B4 de la part de Magnus
par de magie
4 donc la B4 ça s'appelle Laurent outan
c'est une ouverture qui a un nom c'est
Laurent autant
Laurent Houtan donc c'est une ouverture
qui joue pas au niveau alors je crois
que la meilleure ligne contre le rang ou
temps pour ceux qui veulent un petit peu
de culture personnelle je crois que le
coup c'est E5 tous B2 faut prendre les 4
vous prend ici qui avait DL6 je crois
que c'est la meilleure ligne
6 le faux repartira et j'aurai des cinq
les Noirs gagnent plein de temps de
développement
je crois que c'est la meilleure ligne
contre le rang au temps
je crois que c'était une ligne en Honor
en honneur à Laurent Frayssinet alors C6
a été joué
et finalement on est toujours un petit
peu dans les schémas d'anglaise c'est
comme si il y avait eu un C4 prise je
prends et que les Blancs ont gardé comme
un schéma bon anglais c'est quand même
plutôt avec un gâteau mais le schéma un
petit peu de sicilienne vous voyez
B3 est meilleur que B4 et oui
mais 3 c'est B3
tu mets de la musique
doc je t'en mets de la musique on a des
belles pubs avec des belles musiques si
tu veux de la musique tu me dis
ça va vite partir
du monde
c'est c'est vrai cette histoire
Gaby ou ses trolls parce que bon c'est
possible
et
c'est vrai c'est ça ok ok bah écoute
c'est incroyable
B4 c'est Laurent
autant que des quatre on veut vraiment
mettre une caisse en C5
donc là on va on peut pouvoir arriver
cavalerences et après peut-être A4 B5 un
truc comme ça pour les blancs
moi j'aime bien le blanc
j'aime bien les blancs c'est une
position très solide
tu as trompé imaginer les Noirs etc
attaquer le roi blanc cavaler au 5 et 4
voilà
change un peu les pièces ramener un peu
la dame
mais je trouve que l'attaque noire à
laquelle très lente elle va les prendre
en prise
pour que pour revenir ranger 5
une dame en dessin c'est essayer de
faire des choses
pour la première fois à haut niveau
autour d'un New York incroyable
ok ben je savais pas c'était au Central
Park
ah ouais
il y a 100 ans
ramener la dame en H4 ramener la tour en
G5 et essayer de monter une attaque sur
le roi de Naka je vous rappelle que le
sang c'est 2,5 et on avait une
prédiction qui est en cours sur le score
de sur le score de you yangi dans ce
premier set donc on avait enfin le bête
c'était et ce qui fait plus que 2 et
demi dans ce 7 2 et demi qui était le
score
que cheescom et ben avait un peu
comment dire le score que c'est comme
avait
proposé quoi
[Musique]
s'il avait été là Laurent il t'aurait il
t'aurait tellement banne Gaby
il aurait cliqué il aurait bien cliqué
sur le sur le sur le bouton banane moi
je suis pas comme ça moi j'ai pas le
bonnes faciles mais
je pense que s'il avait été là
[Musique]
il aurait pas été il aurait pas été
content il aurait été colère
ton petit message mais moi ça me fait
rire
moi ça me fait rire
alors
alors fou F5
pour passer un petit peu attaque avec
foi
de me défendre
un petit peu
vous voyez
trop bien B5 et de ce côté là il y a pas
trop d'attaque je pense vraiment pas
qu'il y a
à mater la carte
bonne journée à toi Gaby et à très
bientôt merci d'être passé en tout cas
c'était cool
ta marche 4 ah sur la Magic 4 snicky
attention il y a un visa et du coup ça
te laisserait tout reprendre échec et
surprends les deux il y aurait dame
attention toujours au vis-à-vis là c'est
ça peut faire très mal
la F4 qui est un peu mieux plus précis
on prend intéressant pour mettre la
tombe bien et taper sur le pion de B7 à
choisir
pour bien ton B4 l'autre tour en bien
tapé sur pion B7 et
ce pur en B7 c'est un pion qui est
extrêmement faible donc c'est ce qui va
vouloir essayer de faire alors foi faux
F3 on défend le pion G2 tours C8 donc il
veut bouger la dame
la tour pour bouger la dame je sais pas
ce qui va la mettre
il faut défendre le petit pion et je
pense pour B4 et Tours tours bien va
être joué la chose qui n'est pas
d'accord avec ce que je dis c'est quand
même des coups qui ont extrêmement
logique
cette partie elle est pas mal pour les
blancs
pas mal pour les blancs
donc
toujours quand même attention
et quand on a qu'à commencer à danser
c'est très mauvais signe généralement
pour l'adversaire ça veut dire qu'il est
vraiment en confiance et que ça va bien
se passer pour lui
donc tomber avec les jouets tout
recettes
et maintenant il faut terminer un peu le
boulot donc ce fou il est mal placé mais
il est quand même il défend une
faiblesse qui attaqué par deux grosses
pièces donc il fait quand même un gros
job
[Musique]
se foncer vite
les blancs ils ont quand même des
coiffeurs il y a Dieu 4 et du D4 il y a
moyen qu'un de progresser avec les
Blancs
c'est pas évident progresser clairement
dame B8 c'est un coup aussi
un coup je menace tout premier 7 parce
que le fou pourra pas manger il y aura
un clouage alors Dame des j'y penser
mais j'étais pas sûr ça prouve
garde le pion des 7 donc j'ai peur un
jour de voir un tour d'essai peut-être
qu'il y a un fougère aussi qui peut
traîner
regarder
ça ça si je fais ça il y avait 5 donc
j'ai pensé peut-être d'abord jouer H4
ici la tour bouge bon là il y a un
foulard enfilade d'accord comme tout le
tu bouges le la tour je prends là haut
et je prends le 7 sur F5 tu vas avoir
des cartes intermédiaires
au bout de la tour je prends là
un truc comme ça en tout cas ça
réfléchit encore
et je pense peut-être l'idée de de
Nakamura Dame des six l'avait vu H4 full
art et D4 c'est pas étonnant en une
seconde d'accord
le coup de bluff
qui a été joué
par la tour
donc c'est pas encore une menace
H4 TV
ok pourquoi pas
attention que là on a l'impression que
la tour est perdue 4
et et si tu bouges la tour eh ben je
mange là
F5 va être jeu
en place la structure
et il y a plein de problèmes dans la
prochaine noire
c'est pas si grave
pas si grave dans le sens où on Bullet
c'est vraiment un monstre tu apprends à
chaque espace quoi dans le prends là
d'apprendre le 7 ok il veut vraiment
jouer l'attaque
ici Dame des 6 s'il prend là
il y a ça en l'air
et la nul qui peut être péter ici par
pariu
ça répète
tout aussi ça a été joué
refuser la nul
je pense qu'il a raison de refuser la
nuit il est mieux autant
mesdames répétition OK
le pétition pensez à la partie d'après
et je vais vous changer les points
donc deux points pour you tandis
pour ceux qui ont parié sur 2 et demi
deux et demi plus ou deux et demi et
moins attention
n'a plus le droit de faire une seule
nulle il reste 27 minutes et pour pour
que votre pari soit valable et ben il
faut que you il perde toutes ces parties
jusqu'à la fin
jusqu'à la fin de
ce 7 donc vous avez une demi-heure il
faut qu'ils finissent avec une
demi-heure de fait ce qui n'est pas
clair du tout
on gagne 3 2 pour pour égaro à
l'avantage
salut grand maître Gims bienvenue à toi
fous ces quatre cavanes
par contre Karelle le 7 j'avais jamais
vu de toute ma vie
j'avais vu
mais ko qui troll un peu qui veut le
truc qui connaît pas
c'est vraiment de
[Musique]
poser des problèmes pratiques à théorie
je t'en joue aux échec on fait n'importe
quoi il y a pas d'ouverture
OK
peut-être qu'il veut un jour faire F5
qui peut être une possibilité il y a
aussi mais bien un jour sur cavalier G6
et des fois et elle prend
plus tard bien sûr il y a un courage
parce qu'avec ce coup roi je suis vous
voyez il y avait le foot qui calme qui
contrôle la diagonale un jour qui avait
le 6 ça va les prendre j'ai jamais Air
France donc l'idée du style
F6 d'abord F5 après un truc comme ça à
voir
[Musique]
ça fait un trou alors bonne question
Anton en fait
dans ces positions là
puis on prend l'idée des noirs et ça au
final le roi il est protégé parce que on
ira en H8 la torangé vite et on pourra
attaquer sur la colonne g et donc c'est
un truc que moi je jouais aussi avec
avec les Blancs moi j'ai plein de fois
un truc comme ça avec F4 c'est cool
c'est position je connais bien mais
oui oui c'est une possibilité mais il a
pas mangé parce qu'il voulait pas avoir
ce déséquilibre j'imagine mais bien sûr
oui ma caille est en train de streamer
c'est pour ça qu'il parle il parle
autant
avec sa maman il est il est vraiment en
train de streamer
donc F4 comment est-ce qu'on va jouer
ici puis on prend pour prendre cette
thématique
un truc comme ça
pour être
pour être possible
c'est la partie
et il aime pas l'ordinateur il n'aime
pas mes coups
c'est la dernière fois c'est embêtant
c'est plus elle reprend à cause de ton
coin
mais je suis passif
les blancs ils ont un plan qui est quand
même assez facile à jouer ou en tripler
sur la colonne F des vont essayer de
de se placer
à bientôt Jeff sur 23 à très bientôt on
sera encore demain en live demain je
serai en stream à partir de 20h demain
pour un autre match de speech
donc n'hésite pas à revenir très bientôt
donc Tour Eiffel a été joué
et attention j'aime pas la position de
de Nakamura et je vous rappelle que pour
ceux qui ont pris les paris sur les
prédictions tout ça et ben par rapport à
votre pari et ben you qui a les blancs
qui a un très bel position
n'a pas le droit de gagner
en fait il faut qu'il garde toutes ces
parties pour que vous gagnez votre
prédiction
en fait je pense que Papou je pense que
juste il est sérieux quoi
il est sérieux et aux échecs
et il se pose pas votre question
s'il y a beaucoup de gens qui un peu à
l'idée de Naga
je pense qu'il est très très dur à jouer
il a un style très bizarre
[Musique]
mais je pense que juste lui il veut
juste toujours des chèques
et il essaie de pas se prendre trop la
tête
alors c'est quand que j'aime bien
parce qu'après comme tour des 8 je sais
pas laquelle il peut y avoir un jour un
problème
à deux qui peut être un problème alors
tout recettes peut aussi être une idée
bon j'ai mes 7 j'ai aussi des coups
comme dame G4 le mettre un peu chaud
mais ça a pas mal après dans le B2 aussi
un coup c'est la partie c'est un coup un
peu passif je suis pas fan de la
passivité mais bon bah je te fais en
tout je fais 01 et c'est moi qui qui est
la colonneuse c'est moi qui vais venir
en le 7 et je vais faire un choix mettre
mon chat et puis je m'attaque
après il y a encore une heure de Blitz
une demi-heure de Bullet et
stream aussi et vous savez que bon bah
quand il est en stream ben il aime bien
aussi faire un petit peu
[Musique]
faire un petit peu le chaud le spectacle
c'est pour ça qu'il fait des trucs comme
ça bon très moche je te soutiens pas ça
mais juste
je pense que enfin je vous expose un peu
pourquoi et ça un peu mon avis sur la
question
mais
il prend au sérieux enfin dans l'idée il
veut gagner son match vous inquiétez pas
qui va tout faire pour gagner mais par
rapport à ces parties et ben il troll il
troll et ça il a toujours été comme ça
après là il stream et il fait ça mais
vous inquiétez pas quand Magnus il fait
pas ça
là il sait qu'on qu'il le fait you c'est
qu'elle un joueur qui a plus de 1700 €
en classique
donc c'est un super joueur mais par des
formats comme ça il est quand même
largement au dessus d'un cas c'est pour
ça qu'il se permet de le faire
pas forcément mais
c'est comme ça il stream
ok à 4
oui c'est un très bon joueur anglais
mais même encore une fois comparé le blé
qui IRL
avec le
glitch online ça n'a rien à voir
ça n'a rien à voir
pour moi en fait les échecs IRL
et online peu importe la cadence c'est
pas comparable il y a toujours un petit
peu bah oui c'était bon
aussi sur la balade souvent
mais c'est quand même pas comparable
alors B5 a été joué
presque
est-ce que à 500 protéger
[Musique]
et passer la tour pousser mon pion il
tente sa chance Naka
[Musique]
et ce pion qui est gamme dangereux faire
attention tour à un tour à 6 on bloque
ce pion
ma meilleure preuve c'est que le trou
dans les meilleurs joueurs du monde en
blitz il y a tout ou presque sur
Internet
oui oui
c'est vrai c'est vrai mais en fait bon
Carl scène pour le coup c'est avec NACA
c'est les deux meilleurs joueurs
de Blitz et rapide ça c'est clair mais
oui que Magnus c'est lui qui tient le
record de champion du monde Blitz
rapide et en plus il est de partout sur
tous les formats sur Internet aussi mais
lui c'est le meilleur joueur du monde
point barre peu importe c'est le
meilleur joueur du monde
Naka j'ai vu qu'il avait une approche un
peu différente au chocolat du monde
c'est un peu déçu pour vous dire un peu
de comment il jouait parce qu'à la fin
il lui restait des parties il pouvait
rattraper un peu flottant de tête
et en fait on l'a vu Naka faire des nuls
très rapides contre les pommettes comme
ça alors que si bâtonneto il pouvait
revenir sur Carlson par exemple vous
voyez donc c'est un peu déçu par sa
gestion du tournoi
parce que franchement c'est un joueur
qui est capable de tout faire tout
gagner je serais bien aimé voir ce coup
d'un coup d'entre Magnus et Naka au
championnat du monde de bills vous avez
été déçu de toutes ces lignes rapides
que Naga faisait en fin de tournée
donc voilà voilà en plus il a vu le
covid je crois qu'il a pas joué il a pas
joué alors je sais plus c'était Blitz
sont rapides il y en a un qui n'a pas
juste année parce qu'il a eu le covid il
a été testé positif du coup
malheureusement il n'a pas pu jouer
mais bon
ça dépend
et là ça va faire nul
prise mvl au cirque champion du monde et
puis
un Magnus dans un speech
mais après je champion du monde c'est un
tournoi
et je lui dis ça parce que par rapport à
maca et cartienne tout ça mais en fait
Naka il a quasiment jamais vu jamais du
monde il a quasiment jamais joué
une fois il a le covid
etc ok peu importe mais c'est vrai que
Naka et Carlsen peu importe c'est du
live ou du internet ils sont extrêmement
forts quoi qu'il arrive et je pense que
Naka il est encore plus fort quand ça
internet quand même par rapport
par rapport à Carlson
je pense que peu importe
ou pas c'est pareil Naka je pense que
quand ça va encore plus fort que quand
c'est pas internet il a mangé un pion
et écoutez cette position qui devrait
quand même pouvoir faire annuler et à
plus de temps et la casse c'est un gros
filou c'est un gros filou moi j'ai envie
de parler sur une victoire de Dakar dans
cette partie
juste parce que juste parce que il y a
plus de temps
c'est fait un max
non il a encore des cases
l'année au maxime a gagné le champion
ouais ben en fait oui mais en fait si
vous voulez c'est
un tournoi encore une fois c'est un
tournoi combien de fois maxime a mal
joué pendant le weekend pendant que
faisait un super tournoi c'est
là c'est vraiment la forme du moment les
apparisants les trucs pour moi ça a pas
trop trop de
valeur tout ça
comparé comparer ça c'est je trouve pas
trop ça dépend vraiment la forme du
joueur dont on a
et tomber ça tombe ça tombe incroyable
Yuki perd autant
Yuki perd autant cette partie et ça ça
va ça va
ça va
rassurer tous les joueurs qui ont parié
qui ont parié sur sur
4 2 pour yanguer il reste 14 minutes
de match enfin dans ce 7 donc ce qui
veut dire que il reste une partie voire
deux parties donc celle-là voir
peut-être encore une autre derrière
pour clôturer
ce 7 et pour ceux qui ont parié
sur moins de 2 et demi dans ce match là
il va falloir que Naka gagne une partie
très très longue
dans cette dernière partie ou alors qui
met de zéro
lors des deux parties
qui veut toujours il continue quand même
à jouer des trucs bizarres là j'ai B3 au
premier coup mais mes trois c'est un
truc qui joue beaucoup quand même sur
Internet et B3 c'est ça reste un truc ça
reste une ligne un petit peu
dire différent de ce qu'on peut avoir
tout le temps c'est pas le cas c'est pas
des quatre mais c'est pas non plus à 4
parce qu'au début on a vu on l'a vu
jouer à 4 jouer à trois on l'a vu que je
BK on l'a vu tout jouer donc là du coup
B3 ça va ça va
il y a un ami qui vous mettront à Nice
c'est ce qui se fait trop à Nice je
connais pas
en fait c'est un joueur qui est une fois
B3 mais à Nice il y a pas de ami qui
joue commet 3 moi j'avais joué un joueur
un tournoi à Barcelone c'était un maître
chilien qui jouait B3 à chaque fois peu
importe donc qui est joué B3 B3 B3 B3
toute sa vie
rien à d'autres il y aura super cool
je suis content
généralement moi j'aime pas trop je vais
être bizarre comme ça j'aime bien
j'écoute la scie je vois des vrais
ouverture
comme la fille la fille par exemple très
belle voiture
moi je me suis préparé contre lui et
en fait
rapidement l'anecdote le mec qui jouait
jeux P3 et c'est une époque où je vais
demander c'était à l'époque de MSN
j'avais demandé à mvl c'était en 2007 je
crois
mvl a toujours quoi sur B3 avec du coup
D5 fougère et une sorte de pièces et un
peu comme si eux si c'est 6 c'est une
sorte de de slave je dis ok il est sympa
comme ça pas je veux ça il va jouer ça
tu mangeras et tu joueras aussi c'est 6
cavaliers cavaliers le foot etc moi
j'étais content je vais mon système et
dans la partie il m'a joué B3 D5 E3 mais
pas je capte du coup c'est dégoûté là
j'étais hyper dégoûté j'avais le
cavalier F6 et j'avais quand même mais
il m'a fait F3 et en fait finalement
c'était un truc que bref et je
connaissais rien du tout et je t'ai fait
exploser je connaissais pas la position
alors ça relève toute sa vie ses proies
sont à lui en plus c'était bien meilleur
que moi il était maître moi j'avais à
l'époque 2200 hello j'étais beaucoup
moins fort que lui et
donc c'est moins fort que lui et la
position je la connaissais pas voilà
mais pour l'histoire j'avais joué ce
système là
en pensant la fougère
et du coup j'ai pas pu faire fougeratte
j'étais un petit peu
un peu triste
j'aime bien ce que fait dans le cas ici
on double ici on met le 5 on joue F3 et
E4 truc comme ça ça pourrait être pas
mal donc à 4 bien sûr c'est un coup
important je pense un des lois qui ont
envie de s'activer d'ouvrir des colonnes
ouvrir leurs pièces simplement trois
séances de prise
et je sais pas trop quoi d'autre cette
fois-ci
B3 C5
E3 E5
ouais ok
ouais et moi j'aime pas en fait rentrer
dans le jeu des dans le jeu
des blancs d'ailleurs vous savez que
Naka et ben je l'ai battu regardez ma
galerie regardez-le la caméra
je pensais clairement si tu as rien à
faire sur son stream
quel showman ce gars quel chemin ce
matin incroyable
quel showman
j'aimerais bien savoir ce qu'il dit
quand même j'ai rien à savoir si nous
raconte dans cette partie
[Musique]
incroyable
mais les joueurs peuvent se regarder les
gens peuvent se voir
c'est clair quand tu es aussi bon
richeman en fait si tu es que Schumann
et que tu comprends rien aux échecs tu
peux pas faire ça vous voyez mais lui il
peut tout faire parce que le calcul
comme un
comme un ouf quoi
c'est ça c'est incroyable
du coup c'est plus que je disais avant
ça avoir cette histoire ah oui je disais
que j'ai battu ma cave j'ai battu n'a
qu'à les noirs
sur B3
une partie que je pourrais vous
ressortir d'ailleurs
j'ai fait une vidéo sur youtube il y a
pas longtemps où j'ai battu n'a qu'un et
donc ça c'est une partie où j'avais les
blancs c'est une sorte de c'était le cas
de B6 il me semble la partie j'avais les
blancs
mais je répète sur Youtube je l'ai un
petit peu commenté etc par contre je
l'ai battu une autre fois d'accord oui
moi je B3 au premier coup
et j'ai fait des 5 sous G4 le plan que
nous avons fait tout à l'heure
je vous la donnerai la preuve
je
l'ai j'ai la partie
et du coup B3 mais après c'est quand
même une ouverture sérieuse qui est
relativement ça
c'est pas avec 4 par exemple ça reste ça
reste OK
et fou B2 peut-être le fou des cinq va
être une idée avec une étude pion à 4
voilà correcte mais attention quand même
une contre deux
et pour autre Paris je vous rappelle que
on ne peut pas
laisser une nul aye
tous vos points de chaîne
merci beaucoup ciel bleu pour pour ton
petit lien sur la vidéo que j'ai faite
quand j'ai battu n'a qu'à mais celle là
c'est la vidéo où je l'ai battu avec les
blancs mais j'ai une autre partie où je
l'ai battu avec les noirs avec B3 j'ai
pas fait la vidéo hein
je la mettrai en vidéo mais j'ai une
vidéo j'ai battu un cas avec B3 avec les
noirs
cela n'est pas encore sorti
d'ailleurs j'ai eu plein de questions
dernièrement sur la vidéo YouTube que
j'allais faire quand je passais mettre
un international et vous savez que je
passais maître il y a peu près un mois
et la vidéo je l'ai faite elle est toute
faite et je l'ai programmé pour demain
donc la vidéo qui qui sera en ligne à
partir de demain demain je crois demain
15h exactement si vous voulez voir la
vidéo
qui m'a fait passer mettre international
et ben demain
de ma 15 heures
pour aujourd'hui mais comment
aujourd'hui j'étais en stream à 15h j'ai
dit bon allez on va pas mettre l'un sur
l'autre demain 15h il y a la vidéo qui
va sortir
[Musique]
pour aller manger OK
très bonne idée attention 20 secondes on
a perdu pour maca
et vous savez que 20 secondes pour lui
c'est pas du tout un problème il s'en
fout même il est content en fait on
dirait que des fois quand il est mal au
temps il aime bien ça fait un peu plus
le chaud vous voyez il est plus en train
de vivre l'action
je pense que n'a qu'à plus il est mal
plus il a envie en fait c'est ça qui est
horrible
j'ai un pour moi non voilà comme je le
dis yumay
c'est pas du tout ce que je vise après
ben tu me donnes le titre je le prends
direct fous prends un cavalier 5
et je prends là et j'ai quand même une
belle position
il reste quatre minutes sur le temps
réglementaire
donc je pense qu'il y aura encore une
autre partie derrière on va espérer que
Naka mettent de zéro
pour vos points de chaîne
attention
après il peut la gagner en 4 minutes
quand même mais c'est fout le même
couleur donc il m'a même pas la joie il
va pas essayer de pousser
c'est ça sur rocaille en fait
malheureusement moi actuellement j'ai
aucun intérêt à passer grand maître
enfin
c'est pas le fait de passer quand même
c'est le fait de travailler pour devenir
grand-mère c'est tellement compliqué
tellement difficile tellement
d'investissement pour moi
un investissement qui va pas être payant
parce qu'au final je perde beaucoup de
temps et beaucoup d'énergie il y a
peut-être réussir à l'être qui est même
pas sûr
et si jamais je le suis ben qu'est-ce
que ça va m'apporter en fait pas grand
chose donc en fait je vois
investissement et je vois gain et je me
dis ben ça m'intéresse pas tout
simplement après tu me donnes de
l'argent à vie je me pose la question
différemment allez dans la partie de ce
cette j'ai changé le score il y a cinq
deux maintenant pour pour Naka
5 2 pour Naka dans ce match
et attention dernière partie du match si
Naka cette partie
et ben l'après midi va être gagné par
contre s'il n'y a pas la partie
et ben vous pourrez dire adieu à tous
vos points de chaîne même la nul ça veut
dire quoi j'avais dit 2 et demi et moins
vous devez plus ça veut dire quoi
c'était quoi un prédit
je vais regarder
c'était
égal ou moins que 2 et demi ah oui en
fait il faut que Yui garde cette partie
en fait
et en fait vous êtes pas mal là
là je regarde la prédit il y a 20 ans
contre 84
et en fait il faut que you gagne pour
que vous gagniez votre
prédiction ah ouais c'est chaud en fait
pour moi c'était c'était deux et demi et
plus
c'est égal ou moins ouais incroyable
après franchement il y avait un et demi
1 et demi ou trois parties
pas imaginer qu'une heure après il y a 5
2 quoi enfin tu peux mais
[Musique]
alors à 4 étages 5 c'est aussi un coup
mais dommage 5 dommage 4 je pense
dommage 5 on échange
ou pardon d'un congé 6 ou jolie la
progestis je me fais avoir je suis cloué
non du coup je suis pas d'un masque
qui parle pas de moi
pour être pour être aimable avec vous
donc là je suis tu as été joué
et F5 ça va être un coup qui va partir
ça va partir ce F5 je pense que Naka qui
va vraiment terminer ce match après
cette partie donc on prend c'est
obligatoire faut pas laisser F5 est
arrivé donc
et comment est-ce que je joue derrière
c'est pas évident moi j'aime pas trop
cette position avec les noirs de manière
générale parce que
les blancs ils ont un jeu assez solide
j'ai un centre très solide et je mets
pièce qui vont passer comme ça et j'ai
l'impression que le jeu blanc est bien
plus facile que que le jeu noir donc
prise faut prendre qu'elle va les
prendre cavaler au 5 fous bouge et
peut-être dame j'ai 5 maintenant
et ça a l'air quand même d'aller pour
pour les Noirs je crois aussi du F5 qui
peut aussi arriver je pense qu'en fait
ça peut aller carrément pour les noirs
il y avait une partie un peu similaire
ou Naka avec cavalan imbécile c'est avec
le fond en B3 et c'était un peu bizarre
maintenant il y a cavaluer 5 dans toutes
les variantes et c'est pas la même quand
même
bien plus fort que cavalier que cavaler
B6 comme j'ai 5 plus Cavalo 5 ça va être
l'idée la F3 peut être possible je
regarde aller au 5 et le fou
donc là que moi un jour
ça met toujours
même dans le 3 5 qui peut être agaçant
la cavaluation pour moi c'est le coup
numéro 1 qui nage le fou parce qu'elle
est G4 tu me laisses pas mal de choses
on est content on a le jeu on a la
colonel c'est ce qui cherche mais bon
c'est la partie je t'aime trop prise
cavalier prend fou aussi et est-ce que
je peux pas manger ici et manger les
tours ça c'est une décision qui est
assez importante de la part de you mais
le problème j'ai l'impression c'est
qu'en fait il y a ce pion à 4 qui me
pose un peu problème voyons cette
position je me dis que il y a plein de
pions qui peuvent être un peu faibles
chez les chez les Blancs c'est pour ça
que les tours sont pas forcément
meilleures que la lame ici en général
deux tours c'est bien qu'une dame
cette pollution c'est pas clair alors
qu'on a envie d'aller manger les tours
quand même mais celle-là c'est peut-être
pas la bonne position
fou B3 et bien reculer tranquille manger
et il va manger là-haut ben écoutez les
gars j'ai l'impression que Naka va finir
le score sur un petit 6-2 et du coup par
rapport à la prédiction qui est en cours
et ben je pense que
ça a fait plaisir à tous les joueurs qui
si non pas cru en you
F7 en quoi avant
ben là je suis en échec
il faut F7 c'est pas c'est pas possible
tout reste
je comprends pas ta question t-roc
il y avait jamais tout Récept possible
il me semble
oui
tu manges mon pion je te fais échec et
je mange la tour 5 donc le pion il est
pas en prise attention il y a le dessin
que vous voyez il s'en fout du pion
c'est le 7
tu manges tout pour pouvoir faire à la
fin et chaque et j'ai aussi un piège
c'est qu'il y a échec là on voyait
attention au piège
[Musique]
très très mal au ventre
tu manges là tu perds la tour tu me
manques là tu perds l'autre tour
est-ce que tu fais rien je mange là
maintenant ça sans prise parce que le
vrai est parti il y a plus de d'échec
donc si je mange là tu vas peut-être
manger ici je peux manger ici bon
je pense qu'il va manger là c'est la
partie
attention il faut quand même que la gale
pour votre pari il faut que la gagne
très très bonne
option là au tombeau je t'apprends ces
deux petits points qui peut filer un peu
à dalle
d'être là pour pouvoir mettre la tour en
deux mais sur un truc comme ça ça oui
pardon j'ai oublié la tour enfin la nul
suffit il faut que les blancs de gagne
en fait
pour qui vous perdez votre pari et
je vois pas comment les bonnes peuvent
gagner à moins que vraiment il se
prennent
ils se prennent un truc là haut
sur la même d'un point C2 ça fait un nul
après il peut toujours faire un truc où
il y a toujours un moyen de pouvoir
défendre un champion des quatre avec
damlam et 7 c'est un con qui avance tour
à 7
je sais pas si vraiment j'arrive à
regarder un petit peu ce pion tout ça ça
a l'air ça a l'air chaud il prend là à 4
tours
et comment est-ce que je continue
dans les tours sont activants et tu as
plus de tout passer
je pense qu'il va vouloir faire voir G6
peut-être
je sais pas quel moment peut-être à 4
d'abord tour à 7 et roi gs6 parce que le
roi blanc peut pas trop bouger et une
fois que le bouger mon roi je peux me
permettre de perdre G7
et pousser mon pion je pense un truc
comme ça parce que si je fais rien mon
roi va rester là il y a toujours des
thèmes de perpétuel des trucs
parce que là par exemple après tu auras
7 il faut que je joue un couple faut que
je joue un coup et là tu regardes en
plus une menace
H5 3 4 mais j'ai quand même dans mes
deux à prendre ces deux
[Musique]
je suis pas sûr que ce soit grave
je suis pas sûr que ce soit grave de
perdre par exemple je prends un exemple
bizarre si je fais ça tu prends là je
fais ça il y a plus perpétuel mais après
je tente des choses pour essayer
absolument mais après je pense pas que
la casse soit en mustwin il a il a plus
trois dans le match il prend la nuit et
puis voilà peut-être c'est le mieux là
il voit que ça tournait il se dit que si
il continue à vouloir pousser et ben ça
moi j'ai passé pour lui donc il a pris
la lune donc
Nakam qui s'installe avec un petit
fauteuil là de plus 3 dans
dans ce premier set
donc là il y a un petit pause de
quelques minutes pour pour la suite on
va jouer maintenant une heure en trois
plus un je vais vous rendre les points
là pour la prédiction qui était en cours
prédiction donc égale ou moins que 2 et
demi il a fait égal donc c'est c'était
la minorité des 19% qui a qui a gagné
hop je vois les points et si vous voulez
on fera un petit peu la même prédiction
pour le pour le 3 + 1 sachant que je
vais regarder un petit peu les les
prédictions qu'ont
en 5 + 1 avait donné Naka favori il
donnait 6 et demi à deux et demi pour
pour Naka et au final le score ben ça a
été 5 et demi deux et demi donc ce qui
n'intervez pas fait le mariole avec sa
fenêtre 150 coups peut-être qu'il y
aurait une autre partie et peut-être que
si c'est mieux de l'ennemi aurait pu
être le score final en tout cas
maintenant pour le 3 + 1 le score
donnait par fiestcom c'est 6 3 pour Naka
donc
je vais revenir sur ma fenêtre de twitch
et
si vous voulez qu'on fasse
une traduction traduction
qu'est-ce que je peux être en prédiction
le score je vais mettre je vais changer
un peu tout à l'heure j'ai mis également
le score qui est comme je pense je vais
mettre un
[Musique]
trois ou plus et
moins de 3
voilà vous avez deux minutes pour
parier sur le score de U dans le
deuxième scène tu vas commencer votre 5
minutes donc 3 minutes ou plus moins 2 3
c'est comme donne 6 3
pour pour maca donc
ça m'a l'air assez
c'est intéressant de parler là est-ce
que vous pensez que you va faire plus de
ou moins 2 3 alors moi j'en profite au
fond qui pose les gars petite poche on
vient en 3 minutes histoire de me
dégrodir un peu les jambes et je verrai
un peu en revenant je verrai ce que vous
avez fait dans vos paris en tout cas
n'hésitez pas à parier et je reviens
d'ici quelques minutes avec de belles
pubs vous savez que vous adorez les pubs
sur cheesecom je vous dis à tout de
suite
[Musique]
je suis de retour je me suis trompé
encore une fois à deux scènes
et les joueurs qui vont qui vont
reprendre ici quelques instants je vais
voir un peu ce que vous avez fait avec
les prédictions qu'est-ce que vous avez
fait comme
comme Paris je vois quand même 83%
ont parié
on parié moins de trois points pour yo
ok ça marche intéressant
en vrai c'est pas clair parce que là 5
et demi deux et demi la cadence
s'accélère et dans laquelle je pense que
s'accélère plus l'effort donc on va voir
un petit peu
si
il arrive à se reprendre ou pas you mais
c'est vrai qu'on a qu'à en face c'est
tellement fort que
que mais en faisant n'importe quoi en
jouant à 4 combien avec coup
il faut le battre
donc
ok ça va commencer en quelques instants
j'ai pas le
les news
et
ok allez ça va reprendre
toujours pas de partie ici
moins de 3 pour pour généralement chaque
segment on peut faire en grandit parti
du parti max souffrance c'est ce qui est
calculer à peu près une heure et demie
de 5 +
1h de 3 plus 1 et une demi-heure de 1 +
1 allez c'est lancé
ma partie de Blade salut Manu
et du coup d'un cas qui va commencer par
C3
en vrai c'est une blague
parce qu'il a commencé par A3 il a fait
A3 regardez on a qu'un premier coup il a
fait A3 puis A4 puis B4 puis B3 donc là
et la prochaine partie blanc et jouera
ces quatre
si
je tombe pas dans mes stats il a fait il
a fait A3 à 4 B4 q30 et la C3
qui fait un petit Snake avec sa décision
du premier coup à chaque fois
donc ces trois je pense qu'il va jouer
en cadeau la prochaine partie puis je
vois des cadres puis des trois puis
trois bref il s'amuse bien en tout cas
mais en plus il gagne 5 et demi ça le
pire mais en fait j'ai l'impression que
jamais de prendre l'avantage de des
trolls de la carte parce qu'à chaque
fois
même quand le premier coup et ben en
finale il tombait dans une position qui
était vraiment simple quoi il est
toujours de manger dès qu'ils pouvant
des quatre ou quatre et tout une potion
très solide et très simple alors qu'il
peut vraiment essayer je pense de de
compliqué et de
[Musique]
et de rentrer dedans quoi là il avait
fait 5 c'est cool profite de l'avance de
développement des cases noires de tout
ça donc prise
de sang aussi tout va vite là j'ai
l'impression vraiment que les les
blancs sont extrêmement extrêmement mal
attendez je vais faire sortir mon chat
la sieste sinon il va défoncer la porte
hop là
aujourd'hui il fait pas très beau en
chez moi c'est pour ça que Nala elle a
pas envie de rester avec moi
j'ai la fenêtre avec un petit à côté là
généralement on se met sur le lit et
toute la fenêtre tout le soleil sur elle
mais là comme il fait il fait très
mauvais il pleut du coup elle m'aime
plus là
pas envie d'être
sur le lit si il y a pas s'il y a pas de
soleil
alors Dame des deux
a été joué et un gros problème de
développement dans la pollution des
blancs je pense que fou c'est ça
vraiment pas mal avec qui il est empêché
le petit rock et d'avoir des fous trop
des fois si tu veux du Grand rock et 5 a
été joué donc il va laisser faire petit
rock j'ai quand même B6 et 5 mais je
pense franchement qu'il aurait pu
empêcher l'Europe des blancs
pour Naka franchement il faut essayer de
le ficeler quoi une fois qu'il a rocket
je pense ça va la position là
franchement c'était pas mon faux ça va
tellement fort naturel
voilà je l'aime moins mais peut-être
d'embêter à la place je sais pas mais
empêcher le rock quoi ça avait l'air
tellement naturel
très bizarre
full 5
il chante bot vous savez il est très
manager
il danse il chante
il fait son show quoi
il fait son show
donc
là malgré tout malgré le fait que la
réussir à ok la position qui aime
difficile pour les blancs parce que la
part de fou est forte et trou de partout
apparemment c'est une grosse faute
cavaler des quatre comment on punit ça
peut-être dame B6 peut être un coup
sympa
son show
c'est insupportable je crois que dans ce
tournoi là je crois qu'on peut voir son
adversaire en caméra je crois si tu
joues la cas il faut pas la il faut pas
mettre la caméra quoi il a insupportable
je pense qu'il est insupportable quand
tu veux contre lui qui danse comme ça et
en plus qui perd le match il danse juste
ça va plus s'énerver quoi mais je crois
que dans les trois comme ça souvent tu
peux voir la caméra de ton adversaire
et je pense que c'est pas une mauvaise
chose mais quand on a quatre faut pas le
faire en vrai c'est le seul joueur qui
qui est un peu insupportable à regarder
en vrai c'est drôle quand on voit de
l'extérieur mais quand on joue contre
lui je pense que ça peut vite ça peut
vite rendre fou en fait
ça peut vite rendre fou en plus il fait
n'importe quoi toutes les parties
derrière toutes les parties des foutues
quasiment toutes mais après il se défend
hyper bien et les joueurs arrivent pas à
le finir quoi
donc là s'en fout des quatre il y a
peut-être un truc en E2 parce que ça va
les prendre dans la qualité
donc là la qualité de moi il est très
mal mais
bon c'est du blé de ça on va voir un
petit peu
qui va se passer qui avait des F5 allez
contre jeu de la casse sur la case G7
apparemment il y avait un meilleur coup
en tout cas elle est aussi ça j'aurais
pu gagner la qualité ici
mais cavalier quasiment en primo
cavalue 3 c'est quoi ce coup waouh
c'est quoi ce coup dame C3
complètement craqué il a raté MP3
sûrement et encore une fois et encore
une fois un gars qui va gagner et qui
danse
complètement insupportable
j'espère vraiment qu'il le voit pas à la
caméra parce que franchement
tu as envie de brûler quoi
en France comme ça qui fait un peu comme
beaucoup moins fort que dans la gamme et
dans les tournois qu'on avait qu'on
avait
pendant confinement pendant ce truc là
il y avait un joueur français qui était
exactement comme Dakar
et qui dansait tout le temps et qui est
tout le temps essayer de faire ces
barbix et c'est vraiment lui
et un peu insupportable du coup
insupportable c'est quand je parle parce
que je l'ai joué
je l'ai joué il a mangé là il va tout
sacrifier et je vous laisse finale parce
que
on dirait de you allez parti suivante
Naka qui est noir cette fois-ci donc le
score je vais vous le changer ça fait 6
et demi à deux et demi alors cette
portion on est à 0
pas sur twitch et stream sur notre
plateforme qui s'appelle kick c'est pour
ça que tu le vois pas sur twitch ne
t'inquiète pas il est là
il est ici
ah merci beaucoup
pour une fois que
il faut quand même le reconnaître et le
remercier alors c'est 5
tu vas manger ici le feu bouge tu manges
plutôt c'est 7 je dirais ouais parce
qu'en plus c'est un problème sur A7 et
aussi un problème sur le gaz noir ici ça
a l'air extrêmement dur à la fin de la
casser là
je pense qu'on a un gars a bien tilt
dans celle-là mais attention je peux pas
ok encore il y avait c'est ce qui peut
arriver ça peut vite arriver aussi du
côté noir d'en prendre à 7 qu'est-ce que
j'ai fait d'un point à cette menace
maths en V8 quand même souligner
ce que je fais
attention car on attend en B8 cavaler
échec n'importe quoi je vous dis
n'importe quoi donc tous les deux soit
échec là soit la dame ici il faut
défendre le fou et empêcher le bâton de
la prise prise est juste Cavalier rouge
et qu'on rentre F6 c'est grand qu'un
théâtre tu auras un pion mais bon ça m'a
l'air à écrasant pour le lent cette
position
dans ma car il est pas toxique en vrai
ouais il est juste un supportable quand
tu conduis mais il va jamais dire
un truc
qui est grand rock prise pour prendre ou
F4 je garde ce pion en prise c'est très
dur
très très dur
c'est la partie c'est la partie
le coup quand même
qui est joué étrange
F5 il empêche ton F4
et là il menace un roi c'est parce qu'il
y a plus le clouage sur la tour comme
tout à l'heure
pas défendre le pion et je crois que les
Noirs s'en sortent plus ou moins
parce qu'elle a peur de fou quand même
pour les noirs sur le long terme une
fois que je mange ici et que je fais
descendre par exemple la position elle
peut être pas si mal avec les Noirs en
tournant avec les jouets et si je mange
je suis con de faire quoi en fait c'est
quoi ton idée
tu comprends pas trop je vois pas la
pointe en fait
je vois pas la pointe de la princesse
je pense que ça va pour le noir
je comprends pas trop
tu comprends pas
à 5 qui est aussi un coup x 5 un jour
qui peut arriver
mais attention que ce qu'avait les
camions l'air sur tout j'ai 8 et 6 qui
est intéressant
et je pense que la tour serait perdue
après le tour j'ai eu de cavalier ici
dès que tu bouges la tour j'ai quand
même les 8 ce qui fait une fourchette et
en plus une découverte ici
donc là il faut pas jouer de tour G8
mais il faut trouver une autre idée je
pense que la tour elle est perdue en
fait genre limite dépend à 4
obligatoires
vous prend là il faut dire trois mais
il a pris le 4 coups brillant mais qui
en fait
au final le seul coup de fou B
car non c'est pas
tour là d'abord tous les trois il faut
essayer de tenir ce pion en 4 pas de
perdre
pour C5 donc sur fullage d'avoir fou G7
clouer le fou donc noir va partir il est
venu en B2 il faut des trois de jouer
menace torse C2 et sur un coup comme
tour c'est un
ok donc
je pars de l'autre côté des fois H6 qui
va déloger la tour et me laisser la
place pour venir en F2
donc il y a quelques problèmes pratique
quand même encore un point maca qui pose
problème malgré le fait que ben il a une
grippé de moi et que ça va pas mais
chaud quoi
MVS c'est le 11 septembre et firou c'est
le 8 septembre on a le temps encore
mais ça arrive il y a un tableau sur
Just Cause je sais pas si humide est
présent dans notre chat s'il peut encore
nous le nous le remettre vous verrez un
peu le tableau de tous les joueurs au
pion de moins pour un cas
puis on passe à mais à
épinglé aussi je crois si vous voulez
voir un peu le score des Français
qu'ils ont pas encore joué donc
mvl qui joue contre d'ailleurs lors de
ce premier tour des 8e de finale et
fille rouge c'est plus con qui joue je
peux après regarder si vous voulez
peut-être tu peux nous le dire déjà
je crois qu'il joue à un joueur à 2007
c'est pas Savannah mais
il joue un joueur
André Kim
il faut le battre c'est pas pas évident
pas évident qu'avant
mais c'est pas évident comme tirage
et Google c'est pas un tirage aussi mais
je pense quand même que Maxime a de
grandes chances de l'emporter parce que
ok c'est pas sa spécialité le bide c'est
encore moins le online
donc je pense que Maxime gros
favori selon moi
je pense c'est un grand favori
bref je peux me tromper
qui est très très rare qui se bat pour
survivre
à les tours
qui peut arriver
trop de 4 attention
il faut le sein qui peut arriver
et les pions qui avancent c'est Naka qui
a peut-être réussir à s'en sortir voilà
j'avais tout échec
je crois qu'il est hors danger
maintenant quasiment pour G4 le pion qui
est perdu et d'un gars qui est mort de
rire parce qu'il a réussi à sauver cette
partie qui était complètement perdue dur
dur dur pour yoongi pour lui
qui a franchement
pas démérité
vous voyez toutes les parties il est mal
très souvent il est malade et juste
c'est
dur c'est dur de l'achever c'est dur de
[Musique]
ça fait trois points
pour
et 7 pour donc je vous disais vraiment
les
chaque point ou demi point contre
Nakamura c'est c'est difficile parce que
pour le battre il faut vraiment le
il faut le battre plusieurs fois dans la
partie pour gagner la partie quoi ça
demande vraiment une énergie incroyable
et à chaque fois c'est difficile
vraiment c'est dur
et moralement c'est dur
parce qu'au début il y a eu un et demi 1
et demi mais dès que Nakamura il a
commencé à arnaquer une fois ou deux ou
trois you bah en fait tu es plus dans le
match
tu es plus dans le match tu arrives pas
c'est dur
donc
c'est difficile
là on est la fête déjà un quart
du temps réglementaire dans ce deuxième
set qui est dû une heure une heure en 3
+ 1
elle est fous des sacs avec les jouets
fou c'est deux
qui va arriver
il a mangé en premier est-ce que tu peux
manger ici et toujours B4 avec échec
c'était pas clair
c'est simple et B4 là j'avais
d'apprendre à 4 ça va vite mais sur des
4 maintenant fourchette j'avais
d'apprendre à 4
et
maximum de vous aider sur B4 maintenant
je dois avoir un titre d'un échec
intermédiaire qui me permet de pouvoir
plus tard sortir mon cavalier et la cas
qui abandonne cette pollution parce
qu'il perd toute sa pièce après dame là
il y a tout reprend F2 etc donc you qui
vient de gagner une partie très très
vite
dans ce deuxième set on va devoir le son
point
et attention le bête c'était quoi déjà
c'était
trois et plus
et moins 3 je crois donc pour l'instant
et ben on a un et demi il reste 41
minutes en 3 + 1 pour you et
déjà fait un point et demi il y a pas
mal du tout
pour l'instant on est égalité dans ce
match
que je trouverais intéressant dans ces
formes-là donc je pense que ce que vous
en pensez parce qu'en fait vous voyez
que là dans ce dans ce match et ben le
problème c'est qu'en fait un
[Musique]
propose ciel bleu je reviens sur mon
idée après
un truc comme ça et j'ai ma tour qui va
bouger peut-être
et je bon alors attends il est pas
d'accord avec moi avec mon coup de tour
je dois mettre ailleurs la tour
peut-être là
il veut se cacher comme ça OK
donc je revenais sur mon idée de format
vous savez que ce format là on a 1h30 de
5 + 1 une heure encore plus un et une
demi-heure de 1 + 1 et en fait il y a
trois 7 différents avec trois temps
différents trois cadences différentes
et on va ce qu'on fait en fait c'est
qu'on
on a on cumule les points qu'on fait
dans chaque
dans chaque chaque set et puis voilà
quoi
ce qui pourrait être intéressant c'est
de garder un peu ces trois sets mais
aussi de par exemple un peu comme au
tennis là 5 et demi de et demi maca a
gagné le premier 7 maintenant deuxième
set par zéro au niveau des points et
voilà quoi si gagne le 7 même si c'est
par exemple je sais pas
8 7
et ben ça fait un parce qu'on a un 7
chacun et après troisième set etc moi ça
m'a l'air plus juste en terme de 7 parce
que là ce match franchement il est quasi
en fait on a qu'à il est beaucoup plus
fort dans ce cadence là plus ça invite
plus il est fort il y a 7 4 déjà pour
Nakamura et du coup il y a souvent des
matchs il y a plein de matchs où il y a
plus trop d'intérêt après quelques
parties parce que l'écart est tellement
énorme que les joueursont jamais à
refaire leur écart alors que si chaque
set est indépendant je trouve que c'est
c'est aussi intéressant dans l'idée de
d'avoir une chance et de pouvoir se
refaire
donc là c'est cette là si doux il y
avait une chance de pouvoir le gagner et
revenir au score en gagnant 7 ça
pourrait être intéressant mais les
problèmes c'est comme c'est ce qui
compte c'est le total le score des
points cumulés des trois cadences et ben
en fait il est quasiment foutu là
donc ça c'est
le seul petit problème que je vois
à ce format là parce qu'au final le
format je trouve qu'il est cool
mais trois cadrans mettre trois trucs
mais qu'au final
les sept soit
indépendants
[Musique]
oui oui ok mais un tournoi que dans un
magasin
je pense que c'est bien aussi d'être
très égalité
quand même ils vont me tuer allemand en
cas de oui comme au tennis taille break
boum un magasin dès qu'on arrive
ça ça peut être assez intéressant à ce
niveau là mais changer un peu de me
faire des trucs un petit peu
essayer de d'équilibrer un peu les
chances parce que là en fait c'est comme
si on joue au tennis si vous voulez et
qu'on comptait tous les points de chaque
bad de chaque set de chaque jeu et qu'on
cumulé tous les trucs et des fois bah
écoutez là je sens que par exemple que
ben je perds 5-0 en blitz donc en une
demi-heure de jeu bon allez 7 il est
perdu
donc je peux laisser le 7 et après si tu
veux venir sur le prochain set donc des
fois il y a un peu les stratégie essayer
de garder un peu de temps de se reposer
un peu et un peu comme au tennis quoi
tout simplement mais là en fait quand tu
perces 0 dans le premier set juste tu
peux abandonner le match tu pourras plus
jamais rien faire parce que c'est pas le
7 qui compte c'est le score du match
général
et je trouve que c'est
c'est
[Musique]
intéressant mais je préfère en terme de
cette
je trouve que c'est
en tout cas quand le match il est trop
il est trop
on va dire
il est trop inégal en terme de niveau
moi j'aime bien pouvoir avoir une chance
quand même de gagner un set
parce que là il y a trop d'écarts je
pense donc il va pas revenir quoi
dame débute avec les jouets Naka qui
joue très solide qui est mis autant
d'un F4 tourrage 5 je peux le voir
peut-être un est la dame par là ou le
roi comme ça
c'est possible
peut-être juste la tour qui a une
pression sur le plan G5
ils arrivent pas pour l'instant
à le manger donc il va le manger en
obligatoire
[Musique]
qui a une pression toujours un de la
part des blancs peut-être tout ou trois
dame 5 tour H3 et c'est taper sur la
case à chute avec la dame et la tour ça
peut être pas mal cette idée là pour
dame D6 DAF 6 et je fais la même
fuite c'est le coup pour empêcher la
dame de venir ici et là il va y avoir 6
mais
ça marchera pas le blanc en tout cas il
s'est placé
une partie entamée va au bout du chrono
elle va au bout du chrono
peu importe
ok sincèrement une position où on peut
pousser avec les Blancs parce que les
Noirs ont beaucoup de mal à faire des
choses
va être abandonné un couple devra jouer
non il y a une nulle par répétition OK
et alors attends il est pas d'accord pas
répétition l'ordi il est pas d'accord du
tout
on va revenir ici je commence hop je
continue à mettre le score ici
oups
et on est à 4,5
donc je vais juste trouver un peu la
prédiction j'ai un doute sur ce que j'ai
fait moins 3 ou 3 et plus OK
en gros si
you marque un point de plus et ben le
comment dire le pari peut être perdu
un peu de bruit derrière moi c'est
terminé
donc fusée 5 structure un peu de
françaises d'échange ou
complètement égal c'est une position qui
avance symétrique où il se passe pas
grand chose on va peut-être un petit F3
en H4 pour manger des sacs en
contrepartie
là il y a vraiment une position où je
pense c'est une position où peut-être
que Naka va essayer de la jouer pendant
longtemps
position qu'il aime bien qui peut durer
très longtemps de pollution dans
laquelle elle aime bien faire durer les
parties pour jouer le chrono des fois
c'est une position qui est quand même
bien égale
je pense pas qu'il sera retourné ici
en fait je retire ce que j'ai dit
j'aime beaucoup la potion des blancs vu
ce qui s'est passé ici j'ai l'impression
vraiment que après
qui va qui va poser des problèmes à ce
moment adversaire alors que de base la
position a été quand même
symétrique qui est pas là d'avoir
beaucoup de problèmes donc il a mangé la
paire de fou
on peut pas trop lui reprocher ça aime
bien manger la barre de fou là il va
manger d'autre je pense qu'elle est à 5
tours
allez ranger comme ça ok on mange du Fou
ce qui est mieux de garder les pièces
dans la paire de fou comme ça et écoutez
gros avantage ici pour
Hikaru selon moi parce que les fous sont
vraiment trop forts dans ces positions
et en plus à deux pions deux pions
doublés sur la colonne D en dessin car
le 6
à 5,4
par mail pour lancer 6
comment est-ce que je continue alors je
dis B5 toujours qui est possible parce
que c'est comme j'ai la barre de fou il
faudrait ouvrir avec vous donc là C4 qui
a l'air anti-pollutionnel parce que les
pions seraient on va dire dédoubler
c'est un coup qui peut se regarder B5
aussi après t'es pas obligé il a été
gardé la structure intacte et rudymment
mais un peu comme C4 ou 25 pourrait
avoir un intérêt pour ouvrir vraiment
c'est faux et activer toutes les pièces
G4 on prend de l'espace
à la dame allez le droit pardon
va avoir lieu en défend le pion le pion
H4 avec le roi
cavalier ici
en fait on progresse à chaque coup quoi
à chaque coup on va améliorer la
pollution faire des menaces même j'ai 5
c'est un coup aussi on prend qui est
possible j'aurais bien aimé faire la
même chose
sans faire ça F4 attention les deux
carrés sont en prises que j'ai 5 5 ou en
F4 pour pousser un peu F6
c'est dur pour pour
maltraité dans cette partie il est il
est pas bien du tout il est très très
mal
il est très très mal
j'aime bien j'ai 5 ici
j'ai 5 ou 600 jours
tout le temps
qui va un jour être échangé ça donnera
une un peu de vie à la tournoi c'est
pour ça que j'aime bien ça ferme la
tourrage H8 il y a plus de pression
je trouve franchement qu'elle est pas
mal avec les Blancs
mais il faut trouver le
bon plan
G6
F6 il prend comme ça tu as tout refait
ce qu'il veut il va essayer de mettre la
pression sur le pion G6
et en plus après tout réussi j'ai aussi
fou F4 donc pression là il pression là
c'est chaud salut Mister
salut à toi j'espère que tu vas bien
[Musique]
et s'il va être joué un probablement en
cavalier donc je crois je crois pourquoi
je crois
pourquoi une bonne question
je n'ai pas la réponse malheureusement
je peux pas vous le dire
ton G7 surtout F6 il va y avoir canal et
je crois que je viens de comprendre
l'idée non
voiture
c'est pour ça que toi était intéressante
peut-être mais après peut-être que je
dis n'importe quoi je pense qu'en fait
Naka essaye juste de de tourner
cavaliers
éviter toute fourchette oui ben en fait
je pense qu'il voulait juste attendre un
peu et il veut laisser les Noirs jouer
un peu
pour voir si les Noirs vont commettre
des erreurs
peut-être ça l'idée juste
parce que toi aussi ça va quand même pas
mal mais tout réflexe il y avait
toujours cavalerie qui arrive OK
là c'est une position où il est beaucoup
mieux avec les blancs mais où ça va
tourner qui veut dire que
il va faire plein de choses il y a fou
qui va venir un jour un pour dévore le
pur H4 le roi qui va partir se promener
quelque part
et on va voir un peu mais fous ça va
être joué c'est quasi sûr
un tour bien aussi un coup qui peut être
joué trop bien ça a l'air pas mal quand
même
[Musique]
ok il va où
à 3 s'il prend ici et tu reprends là
du coup c'est quoi
manger F5
tous les pions noirs sont faibles
maintenant simplement c'est protégé tour
échec qui va arriver
allez bouge pas à cause de tout droit et
tout le temps va les bouger
j'ai 6 il prend tout aussi si on prend
le cavalier c'est magnifique ce qui nous
fait ici
monter le roi ici mettre le foot
peut-être en E5 un jour aussi ça a l'air
complètement terminé pour la casse
l'histoire au F4 rang G5 peut-être la
rouage 6 il y aura fou et fuite maths 6
ma prise cavalier prend roi là qu'elle
va les prendre ici ça se calcule ça a
l'air très très chaud on prend F5 plutôt
prise ça va gagner pour les blancs
moi je vois ici
G7 ramener le roi c'est juste abandon et
en plus ça perd autant ouais très très
bonne technique de Nakamura ici assez
impressionnant
[Musique]
8 et demi à 4 et demi et toujours deux
points pour you dans ce set donc encore
26 minutes
à jouer et Yuki est parti
e4a5 il s'en va
[Musique]
en vrai en vrai ça rend fou et pourquoi
est-ce que
ce qu'il est parti prendre un boire elle
est partie aux toilettes où est-ce qu'il
arrache quitte le match parce que Naka
joue A5 et qui le et qu'il entre
guillemets l'arnaque et est-ce que
se passe-t-il la partie a été supprimée
chez moi
ah c'est la pause excusez-moi c'est vrai
je me disais bien entre chaque entre
chaque
[Musique]
cadence et ben ça repart à zéro donc là
en fait ce qui se passe c'est que
on a une heure de trois plus un on
arrivait à la moitié de 3 + 1 donc les
gens sont partis en pause et moi je
comprenais pas pourquoi il était parti
après avoir jeu 4 à 5 la partie a été
annulée mais ça je l'avais pas vu donc
petite pause pour les joueurs je vais
profiter pour en faire une moi aussi
très rapide et je vous laisse une pub
chascom et je vous dis à tout de suite
saviez-vous que vous pouvez pimenter vos
parties en ligne et vous analyser avec
des emojis il vous suffit de cliquer sur
l'icône emoji puis de sélectionner votre
emoji et de cliquer avec le bouton
gauche de la souris sur l'échiquier vous
pouvez choisir parmi une multitude de
notation de coûts d'animation
d'émoticônes et même vos personnalités
préférées du monde des échecs des
émoticônes et les emojis disparaîtront
au bout de quelques secondes en revanche
les notations de coûts et les animations
spéciales restent sur l'échiquier
jusqu'à ce qu'elle soit effacées pour ce
faire il suffit de cliquer avec le
bouton gauche de la souris sur l'emoji
ou de cliquer sur le bouton Tout effacer
essayez tous et amusez-vous bien sur
Chess.com
vous les streamer des échecs comme vos
créateurs préférés tels que Blin stream
Naka ou les soeurs
le programme de Community streamer de
Chess.com est fait pour vous débutant
dans le streaming ou déjà expérimenté
peu importe c'est le moyen idéal pour
élargir votre audience vous connectant
votre compte à cheese.com et profiter de
la visibilité offerte alors d'autres
plateforme de jeu il vous suffit de
relier votre compte à
cheese.com/settings/connecting
mettre échec comme catégorie sur twitch
et commencer à streamer
d'une expérience sans publicité sur
chaise.com et apparaîtrez dans notre
liste de streamer en direct votre profil
affichera votre stream twitch qui sera
aussi mis en avant durant vos parties
offert utiliser la commande community
streamer dans le chat faites grossir
votre audience sans plus attendre
[Musique]
je suis de retour avec les joueurs qui
qui vont arriver dans quelques instants
alors est-ce que je voulais cette petite
cette petite scène là où est-ce qu'on
peut faire l'autre d'avant dites-moi un
petit peu on va changer un peu un peu
les choses est-ce que vous préférez pas
un petit peu les les grosses scènes
les grosses scènes
[Musique]
où on va mieux les joueurs
parce que vous préférez la scène
que vous me voyez aussi
pas du tout indispensable
au stream en tant que visuel mais
[Musique]
si vous voulez celle-là elle est pas mal
aussi je peux essayer de vous mettre un
peu plus centré
je peux essayer de
[Musique]
parce que
il y a un petit trou à plat
Bob le truc qui préfère avant dites-moi
un petit peu là
par une
allez on fait une minute
dites-moi rapidement ce qu'on fait
est-ce que moi les grandes cannes comme
ça ou est-ce qu'on met les petites comme
avant avec ma tête je vous laisse voter
très très vite
voter voter vous avez qu'une minute
ce qui ne vote pas ne pourront pas se
plaindre
ce qui vote pas pourront pas se plaindre
4 4
6x4
je vois quand même que je suis populaire
sur le stream ça fait plaisir
c'est ça ça mérite de voter pour
l'ennemi du coup ça lui routes
la stuff cam
tu mettes grandement en votant blanc
maugré
la partie qui a commencé d'ailleurs
la partie a commencé
je crois quand je vais devoir remettre
ma caméra
j'aurais dû
j'aurais dû mettre 10 000 pour voter
comme ça j'aurai gardé cette vue pendant
10 minutes ça te fait une partie comme
ça
du coup ben je vais remettre ma tête et
Nakamura
et coucou je suis revenu
allez c'est parti
c'est dur mais bon après quand tu es là
tu gagnes dans les prix quoi qu'il
arrive donc
ok donc une partie c'est encore une une
écossaise Neco 16 un peu bizarre
regardez on va faire rapide très vite il
y a eu cette anec B3
d'un des deux fous de fois
pendant un F5 et apparemment c'est
complètement gagnant pour les blancs
cette position alors comment est-ce
qu'on termine ça d'un point et
d'apprendre à cette
qu'elle a pas mal
je prends des notes
hop
est-ce que l'image est en direct avec
les coûts non c'est en direct
je t'assures en fait route
je crois qu'il y a un décalage de 15
secondes
je crois qu'il y a 15 secondes de
décalage c'est pas c'est pas une minute
comme on avait hier c'est 15 secondes il
me semble
alors tourner
dans ma F6 et là est-ce que comment on
passe qu'avait les B5 à l'arbres coudes
aussi alors pas mal non plus fou B2 elle
a un très très fort aussi
là il y a du cavalière qui va qui va
arriver
vite et qu'elle va de la 4 ça a l'air
très bien
ma 4 à 5 aussi a l'air très fort à 4 à 5
à 6
il y en a qu'un qui fait pas le malin
c'est parti
il danse plus vous voyez il danse plus
il chante plus
mais si elle arrive à ne pas perdre
cette partie et ben il va se faire la
partie en chantant
et il faut pas que ça arrive
cette partie il arrive à trois points
dans ce set c'était trois et bus je
crois
ou 3 et moi
[Musique]
je crois c'est 3 et plus que j'avais dit
pour le pari il me semble
donc à 4
a été joué et c'est extrêmement dur à 5
arrive à 5 cavaliers bouffes cavaliers à
4 la dame monte en l'air il y a
absolument tout en l'air
même à 5 jours prenez un peu cavalier
cette déjà
on va apprendre d'apprendre au moins ça
peut-être même plus encore
vous comprenez un petit peu là la
pauvreté de la position
je pense c'est foutu en fait parce que
même cavalier à 8 cavalier à 4 même
Damas
je pensais avoir un truc j'allais signer
mais
ça va pas être normal tout ça
vous allez avoir des trucs
tactiques même ça ça non je pensais je
commence à avoir des photos de partout
des gens je pensais B4 si tu prends je
te prends ici je commence à louer dans
tous les sens
je crois que
ça va pas du tout c'est lui qui a été et
oui ça y est ça y est je n'ai pas mis
pour faire
pour troll c'est la vérité et à 6 a été
élevé par U
range
à 6 j'ai x 6
je comprends rien je comprends rien
je sais pas
eu de plaintes sur quoi que ce soit
aujourd'hui je pense que mon son il est
assez OK
d'après mon pensant que l'autre cavalier
je sais pas en fait il y avait quand
même du contrôle
sur jeux de 1 peut-être mais
à 6 je sais pas si c'est un multiplic ou
pas dans tous les cas ça reste quand
même
ça reste quand même difficile ici
j'ai pas d'âme débite mais là on sent
qu'il y a des thèmes de partout
cavalier chaque qui a va dépendre
le cavalier ici et Yuki va décoller au
score Yuki qui revient à trois dans ce
set
et Yuki revient pas mal au score là hop
à 5,5
alors rapidement c'était quoi j'avais
dit alors je regarde tout le temps je
j'ai une mémoire poisson rouge avait dit
moins de 3 ou 3 ou plus du coup ce qu'on
va faire comme il a trois et ben je peux
encore une fois choisir le résultat donc
je vais du coup
[Musique]
je vais finir cette prédiction
et on pourrait en faire encore une autre
si vous voulez le prédiction
pour voir un petit peu ce qu'on peut
faire de ça j'ai payé
[Musique]
j'ai payé les gens avec les prédictions
qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec ces
prédictions
la jauge je pense que
je pense que la jauge elle est pas du
tout normale je vais essayer de
la jauge qui marche plus
la chose qui marche plus je crois on l'a
cassé
on a cassé la jauge
ouais
elle est complètement cassée on est
revenu on a
est-ce qu'on se fait une une
prédiction pour pour la prochaine partie
alors la prédiction qu'on peut faire je
vous propose c'est pas sur celle-là
c'est sur la celle d'après parce que là
vous avez déjà vu la partie là ça va
être compliqué si on fait les
prédictions alors que alors que la
partie il a déjà commencé il reste 2000
chacun mais si vous en fait une
prédiction sur la partie d'après
quand je vais que la pollution est
quasiment terminée et ben on se fera une
prédiction
juste sur la partie c'est quand même
bien de pouvoir prendre des paris
ça mixe un peu les déchets
tu as vu que ça ma bienvenue à toi
donc
tourner un tour c'est un qui fait une
grosse partie là
j'aime beaucoup la prochaine des quatre
va arriver il y a un problème quand même
un peu de partout qui avait des B5 pour
aussi être une idée plus tard
et c'est dur
c'est dur pour pour nous je pense dans
cette partie
3 F7
avec les jouets qui avait laissé pas mal
tu as une belle carte dans des six pour
un cavaler la voyez j'ai aussi assez en
l'air c'est aussi des vis-à-vis ici
franchement j'aime beaucoup beaucoup la
position de maca mais cavaler de B5 mais
là
ultra obligatoire
et je sais pas ce qu'on veut d'ailleurs
faire
soit 5 cloués par un aussi
faux F3 donc il attend un peu il fait de
l'aller-retour
je peux encore je prends une fois ici
et après je prends là et je prends là
avec un tempo ouais c'est superbe je
pense
là et je prends là il fait ça en fait
je pense que c'est juste perdu
il a mangé comme ça OK
en fait il pense que les pions à 7 sont
perdus
qu'il a raison c'est le plus simple en
fait en pratique
j'ai choqué ça j'ai ça j'ai à peu près
tout qui va gagner les pions
et il va gagner alors prédiction que je
vais faire c'est pas sur la partie qui
arrive d'accord la prédiction que je
vais que je vais faire dans quelques
secondes ça va faire sur la partie
suivante ou u aura les blancs
de la partie
j'ai marqué
[Musique]
ganaka
je mettrais en 30 secondes par contre ce
sera express
dès que ça commence je l'envoie
dès que ça commence je l'envoie alors
qui archi gagnant il va pousser le pion
là vous voyez à quel point il est fort
ma car il a quand même deux minutes
d'avance à la pendule position gagnante
vraiment le Blitz c'est vraiment son
domaine
[Musique]
ça va être abondant
alors que je vais lancer très bientôt la
prédiction elle four environ des 6 pour
prendre les cartes de cavalier parce
qu'il va jusqu'à valeric
je compterai toutes les cases du
cavalier et j'ai plus qu'à ramener mon
roi et à manger les pions il y a gagné
donc il se bat encore un peu
la vallée
elle est fous là et à 7
allez car il est encore
et qui sort plus maintenant on ramène le
roi
ça va être abandon allez s'abandon j'ai
lancé la prédiction si vous voulez
j'ai lancé la prédiction
pour la partie qui arrive avec Naka qui
joue à 5 au premier coup mais ça c'est
pas une surprise vous savez ça va rien
changer par rapport à vos à vos
à vos paris vous avez que 30 secondes
donc dépêchez-vous à tout miser
dépêchez-vous il reste plus que quelques
secondes pour miser ça bien sûr je mets
30 secondes parce que vous imaginez bien
que si vous mettez le plus de temps vous
allez avoir trop d'infos sur la partie
donc ce serait pas juste
et on fera ça un peu si vous voulez à
chaque partie je sais pas si Yuma il est
encore là dans le chat est-ce que Yuma
est présent
où est-ce que est pas présent
charger des prédictions
ou si je le fais moins à chaque fois
faut prendre des 7
absents
comme à 14h mais là
[Musique]
ça fait quand même deux fois d'affilée
quasiment que you avec les Blancs il
gagne en
deux minutes
c'est you la gagne j'ai vu qu'il y avait
il y avait un petit rigolo sur le chat
qui avait qui a mis all-in sur la
windonaka ça peut faire mal ça peut
faire très très mal si n'a qu'à venait à
perdre cette partie
dame décès a été joué attention et puis
on va jouer
donc
que les blancs sont un total contrôle
mais plus à jour plus les noirs sont pas
si mal regardez en fait sur case blanche
je passe plus de l'autre côté tout est
bloqué là dans le contrôle B4 le
contrôle ici
le roi il est totalement safe qui avait
les pas rentrer il y a pas de case pour
rentrer avec son cavalier
franchement je commence à bien aimer les
chances de Naka alors qu'en début de
partie il devait être complètement
perdant
mais encore une fois c'est l'objectif
c'est le bled c'est ma car il fait il
est comme ça il joue au premier coup à 5
qui trollent il troll de fou mais il
arrive à ne pas perdre quoi ça c'est
incroyable
je pense franchement que il fait trop
t-il ces adversaire quoi c'est dur de
jeux qu'on a qu'à il fait n'importe quoi
et il est tout le temps perdant dans les
ouvertures
parce qu'il troll trop mais malgré ça il
te bat quand même quoi tu arrives pas à
le finir
c'est une sensation qui doit être
vraiment très difficile surtout quand tu
es quand tu es un joueur à 2700 hello
comme comme Yu
un jour à 2007 tu arrives pas à le finir
alors qu'il fait n'importe quoi dans
chaque partie
là rapidement pour le début ça avait
l'air perdant complètement là après
Damas 4
c'était quoi
attendez
c'était pas si clair ok bon ça avait
l'air quand même pas mal ton rêve 3 F6
qui a Rowling je sais pas
malheureusement j'ai pas le nom j'ai pas
le nom des
una bien se tenir
pas mal
ces billes qui a mis un quart sur la
drogue
qui est pas mal vous partir au final une
fois que je fais le 4 ça va ça va raser
un très gros centre et au final j'ai
plus de faiblesse
à la pendule
c'est juste terminé en fait
cette partie m'a l'air juste en fait
termine à
j'ai pas le nom des joueurs qui ont qui
ont misé malheureusement ah si j'ai un
nom j'ai pas le TOS qui a misé 44 sur un
40 cas sur Naka
qui est toujours ici cavaluevin ça va
tricoter
il y a trop de problèmes avec 20
secondes à la pendule c'est intonable
c'est intenable en plus qui tricote qui
va laisser aucun contre le jeu
tout le temps
un peu quand je veux
je vois pas encore le plan de gain pour
les
pour les Noirs mais à trois tortilla ici
et encore une fois n'a qu'à toujours
deux minutes d'avance sur la pendule ça
fait deux fois d'affilée il a
qu'il a
[Musique]
à la fin 2 minutes quoi complètement
injoueur
les points qui s'envolent on part sur la
suivante
Naka qui marque un dixième
point et demi en plus
est-ce que vous voulez encore une
prédiction
j'ai fait un biscuit là
je vous refais la même malheureusement
est-ce que je peux refaire la même
qu'avant il y a pas un bouton qui me dit
la même qu'avant
ouais c'est bon on se fait la même si
vous voulez
la même prédit
vous avez 30 secondes par contre pour
les pour les prédictions il faut aller
vite
parce que je veux pas trop mettre de
temps et bien un cas c'est quand même
osé hein Naka il peut pas gagner toutes
les parties non plus je vois qu'à chaque
fois vous mettez vos lignes sur gang
assez bien mais
il suffit qu'il gagne
qu'une fois il perdent et là vous parlez
tout ce que vous avez
165 cas sur Naga je vois que vous êtes
très généreux avec Naka
non enfin ouais c'est vrai que
n'a qu'à en fait il était tellement
difficile à jouer dans ces dans ces
cadences dans ces dans ces formats dans
ces tournois que c'est hyper difficile
en fait c'est trop dur et
en plus je crois que par rapport au prix
alors si je n'ai pas de bêtises je sais
pas dans le dans le chat peut-être que
vous connaissez mieux que moi mais si un
joueur arrête avant la fin du match on
peut en donner j'ai le droit par contre
si j'abandonne je crois que je prends un
pourcentage
du prix auquel j'ai droit par exemple si
je perds par exemple je prends admettons
je sais pas 5000 dollars
et ben si jamais je pars
en rage quitte le match je finis pas le
match au lieu de prendre 5000 je vais
prendre peut-être 50%
ou 70% de comme ça de du prix que je
devrais prendre donc soit tu continues
le match de l'argent et donc jusque là
j'ai dû personne rage quitte tout le
monde va jusqu'au bout
mais un jour on aura peut-être un joueur
qui est rage quitte on verra bien
mais
oui à la fin quand il y a trop trop de
d'écart mais bon en vrai
[Musique]
généralement il y a pas trop d'écart
entre les joueurs ils arrivent toujours
à se
jamais clair quoi à part d'un cas et
et Magnus
vraiment une en stream
il y a un décalage de 15 secondes
pernicieux
ouais il danse ouais je sais c'est
ça rend fou moi ça me rendrait fou mais
bon qu'est-ce que tu veux faire
il stream il a le droit il fait ce qu'il
veut
cavalier H5 attaque le fou
un peu dans l'ouverture il fait
n'importe quoi exactement il fait
n'importe quoi et
il te tremblement de faire n'importe
quoi et à gagner en plus et à danser
bref
ce tirage je compte Naka c'est
franchement pas un cadeau parce que il
est il est vraiment très dur à jouer par
rapport à tout ce qu'on vient de dire en
fait déjà il est très fort il fait
n'importe quoi et en plus il a
la barre oui elle peut faire un peu
n'importe quoi
mais
dans le 7 ou 4
alors les respect
[Musique]
en vrai je pense qu'au tout début de ces
événements on voyait on pouvait le voir
un peu comme de les respecter
mais en fait maintenant tout le monde
sait qu'il n'a cassé d'accord et que
c'est un streamer professionnel
et en fait comme c'est la cas et ben les
gens le prennent bien enfin bien non je
pense pas qu'on prenne bien mais tu
prends pas aussi mal que si vraiment on
voulait du millier enfin je sais pas si
tu fasses le dire
il fait son show il stream il fait son
truc quoi donc c'est pas contre toi
c'est juste qu'il fait son spectacle il
fait son truc et c'est vraiment pour ça
que
vous voyez je
voilà après je sais voilà Laurent je
sais que
je me demande c'est quoi ça limite base
de l'eau pour aller trop loin je pense
que c'est
top 10 mondial quoi
je pense au top 10
et là il a raté apparemment est un point
de 4 c'est perdant encore une fois you
qui va perdre cette partie il va manger
là à la fin il y a ça en l'air mais il y
aura toujours la tour en l'air avec le
fou
après même Magnus qui va lui jouer à
trois fois mais il va pas continuer
d'envoyer là Nakamura il a fait le
premier coup il a fait des trois hein
premier coup il a fait des trois voyez
on est vraiment dans la continuité donc
prochaine game il va jeter quatre ou
trois attends je sais plus où on en
était
[Musique]
il change il a commencé avec A3 après il
a fait A4 après B3 B4 C3 C4 et la date
des trois
donc là il va ajouter 4
à moins qu'il ait déjà fait avant j'ai
pas vérifié
il fait
il fait tous les coups comme ça
il va s'amuser
le 4G ouais là c'était quand même
différent c'était un
que d'ailleurs je crois qu'un a gagné en
jouant j'ai 5 à toutes les parties
donc bon il y en a qui a encore gagné
cette partie
les victoires je vais devoir remettre
et ouais bon après Maka c'est un peu
pour lui l'échauffement je comprends que
c'est difficile mais bon c'est comme ça
et je remets la même prédiction
30 secondes pour la prédiction c'est
parti si vous êtes chaud
c'est un peu comme mon casino on mise le
rouge en milieu noir mais là c'est quand
même deux parties d'affilée ou Naka
[Musique]
comme ça
là c'est pareil il gagne deux parties il
peut encore et puis encore ah
franchement je dis attends ça va il y a
8 mois ça va être rouge maintenant mais
aux lignes sur rouge et c'est noir
[Rires]
j'en ai pleuré
toute ma vie ça alors dommage 5
oui c'est indépendant en fait mais juste
dans ta tête tu dis non mais non ça va
changer en fait à chaque fois ça
mais bon
c'est la vie
pour tous ceux qui ont la roulette dans
leur vie
comprendrez
c'est pour ça que la Naka il est à deux
donc on va filer il peut très bien aller
à la troisième c'est indépendant ça ne
change rien et pour ceux qui misent
contre et ben voilà
c'est vrai que le cerveau c'est vrai tu
sais que c'est indépendant mais tu dis
non mais quand même
la relatus jamais de ma vie et je pense
qu'il met que je n'aurais pas du tout
j'aurais jamais
salut albanvier bienvenue à toi sur le
stream
comme dommage 5 joué par you mais
c'était pas frise Naka mais non il est
pas prise
franchement je pense
à tout l'argent que des gens ont pu
perdre parce que t'imagines six mois à 5
6 je dis ouais solide sur le noir tu
vois ça change de couleur et là à 26
combien ah oui le reste pour gagner
c'est ouf c'est ouf l'argent qui ont dû
gagner avec ça donc ça faisait nul je
pense direct et you il a il a pas voulu
faire nul parce que il s'en fout quoi le
match est terminé certes mais bon tu
joues quoi
dans tous les cas quasi cool quasiment
la plus perte beaucoup mais combien il a
gagné sur les 26 coups précédents
je pense que ça va
le Paris c'était trois points 3 points
ou plus donc j'ai déjà rendu les points
batteur concave j'ai rendu les points et
d'ailleurs là on fait d'autres
prédictions sur chaque partie
chaque partie qui se joue et d'ailleurs
ça c'est la dernière partie du cercle
parce que vous voyez que le temps en
haut à gauche et ben il sait désactiver
donc c'est là c'est la dernière partie
du 7
le score c'est 11,5
en faveur de
Nakamura la jauge elle bloque des fois
ouais faut que j'actualise chaque fois
mais elle se bloque la jauge
et là c'est la 18e partie entre you et
Nakamura
tour D8 et Naka qui risque de encore
gagner cette partie qui est quand même
extrêmement fort
pas comment on peut
continuer ça
et c'est d'échanger un peu les pièces
alors moi j'ai déjà battu un joueur
10 0 en pile ou face
et c'est pas une blague j'avais fait un
match depuis deux faces je me sens c'est
un Barcelone
et son truc
et du coup tout le monde dit j'ai de la
chance au jeu mais c'est pas vrai c'est
pas vrai ça c'est un mythe j'ai pas de
chance au jeu mais tout le monde pense
que j'ai tout le monde pense que j'ai
beaucoup de chance
parce que j'ai gagné 10 euros en pile ou
face
a été joué tourné
4 le pion qui est
toute façon quoi qu'il arrivait et je
pense que ça va être un gain noir
à mettre le fond en B2 et à défendre le
pion à 3 ça aurait été génial mais j'ai
pas du tout vu que je perdais l'option à
trois donc là il y a un pion en plus
pour les Noirs mais c'est un pion de la
même aile donc c'est pas clair du tout
bien sûr plus je pour gagner mais une
nulle serait pas du tout
scandaleux ici
pour prendre il faut prendre changer les
dames faute de te reposer ça serait nul
donc on décide on joue la finale de
dames avec un pion de plus et cette
partie la brique Naka a aucune raison de
vouloir la continuer un milliard de coup
cette partie parce que le Timer est à
zéro alors que s'il y avait encore
beaucoup de temps peut-être que
de pouvoir la jouer un milliard d'un
coup celle-là
même des 6
Roy F6 peut-être il y aura des chèques
là
attention
le but c'est par derrière comme ça
je sais pas comment je peux m'en sortir
des échecs qui arrivent
pas simple du tout à la passer celle-là
il y a des blancs ni avec les noirs
en tout cas ceux qui ont parié pour la
victoire de Lyon désolé ça va pas se
passer
il y a eu 5 % des
gens qui ont parié sur la victoire de
you 20% sur la mule et 75% sur la
victoire de Naka et là c'est pas clair
encore
15 secondes chacun
il peut se passer encore plein de choses
pour cette partie
n'est pas qu'il y a déjà
une belle avance dans ce dans le score
on voit 11,5
mais il veut enfoncer le couteau dans la
plaie
l'exploser en fait
je me posais la question
ça tourne ça tourne ça tourne
E3
d'un champion et ça ça va être perdu
coco la finale il faut l'avoir
elle va faire mieux le gamin F3 et 4 qui
doit faire nul direct quand même donc
j'ai 4 pour avoir un petit peu à côté de
l'opposition
et ça fait nul là
attention attention à toi mais 0 à 4
tout le temps
qui fait nul
il y en a qui essaye tout jusqu'au bout
mais ça fait nul grâce à l'opposition
et je mets en face l'opposition et ça
fait nul
ça va faire nul tu as quand même que ça
fasse nul pour de vrai
je vais choisir le résultat
oups
sur le résultat
et ça fait nul donc joueur qui partent
en pause maintenant dans
[Musique]
pour le faire pour partir avant le
dernier set donc on est à 12,6 Naka qui
part ambulette il aura les blancs dans
la première partie avec 6 points
d'avance quand même avant le dernier set
c'est quand même
quand même pas mal c'est une belle
avance pour Nakamura c'est quasiment
quasiment pervers en fait donc je fais
une petite pause de trois quatre minutes
et je reviens d'ici trois quatre minutes
pour la fin de ce match pour le
troisième set donc une demi-heure de une
plus une je vous dis à tout de suite
quel est le meilleur moyen de suivre
n'importe quel événement échiquier
surpris a du monde au tournoi des
candidats en passant par le speechess ou
les title Tuesday
chase.com/avance court tous les plus
grands tournois d'échec il se déroule en
présence ciel ou en ligne vivez
comprenez en direct les parties des
meilleurs joueurs de la planète avec les
commentaires en français de nos experts
notre moteur d'analyse l'explorateur
d'ouverture et les tables bases
retrouvez toutes les infos essentielles
comme le programme les horaires des
rondes les prix les résultats les
comptes rendus quotidien les bio des
joueurs les règles des partages et plus
encore vous pouvez même participer à la
compétition en pronostiquant les
résultats pour tenter de gagner des
abonnements premium alors rendez-vous
dès maintenant sur chess.com/avent ou
c'est bien sur le site internet que sur
nos applications iOS et Android pour
vivre votre passion comme nulle part
ailleurs
[Musique]
je suis de retour alors que les joueurs
s'installent et qu'on va reprendre
on va se faire une dernière prédiction
sur l'ensemble du 7 de Bullet
alors rapidement avant de vous mettre ça
cheescom propose enfin en tout cas la
pression c'est
8,2 pour Naka en une plus simple
du coup je vais faire comme ce que j'ai
fait avant je marquais 2 et plus
je vais marquer
deux ou plus
et moins de 2
non je marquais je marquais
j'ai marqué
[Musique]
2 et moi ouais
et plus de deux je pense
ça me paraît plus faire
allez vous avez deux minutes
pour parier
sur le score de U dans le troisième set
de Bullet en vrai c'est pas clair c'est
assez
qui gagne plein de plein de parties
mais vraiment enfoncer le clou ou alors
être vraiment relâché et Yuki peut
revenir clairement au score enfin au
score pour pas revenir car mon score
même
Yuki qui peut revenir et gagner plein de
parties donc là vous avez encore environ
une minute 30 pour voter pour tous vos
points de chaîne
pas mal que les votes c'est gratuit vous
parlez que des points de chaîne c'est
des points fictifs
ça c'est la petite bulle qui est en
dessous du chat là vous avez une petite
bulle avec des points à côté ces points
là qu'on met en jeu dans ces petits
Paris
alors j'attends encore les parties
qui arrivent est-ce que pour cette
portion de Bullet est-ce que vous
préférez
cette vue par je sais que vous aimez
quand je suis là mais est-ce que le fait
d'avoir du Bullet vous préférez voir un
peu mieux les joueurs est-ce que vous
préférez avoir un gros plan dessus
où est-ce que vous voulez avoir la scène
d'avant dites moi ce que vous préférez
d'un cas il y avait un cadre mais ça je
peux cadrer facilement
et nous qui aime bien cette cette scène
pour le Bullet peut-être pour le Bullet
ça ça a du sens
Naka qui peut être un peu mieux cadré
ambulette ça peut être pas mal
elle est plus que quelques secondes pour
le pour les paris faites vos jeux rien
ne va plus
allez donc on a cette scène là pour le
Bullet après c'est un qui aime pas du
tout on pourra changer de scène on n'est
pas obligé de garder toujours celle là
mais ça permet de changer un petit peu
un faux 3 et un cas qui veut extrêmement
vite dans ce portion prise F4 il va
jouer F5
prise
cavaler des deux on sort les pièces il y
a quelqu'un qui joue extrêmement vite il
y a plus d'une minute à la pendule après
20 coups
par contre tout droit la jauge elle aime
pas du tout
ce coup mais alors pas du tout
la bouteille c'est quand j'ai 8 ans donc
je vois pas trop pourquoi ce si fort que
ça
tourne je débute avec les jouets
quand même plutôt mal oh B8 H 4 H3 pour
être une idée plus tard
prise fou G4
dame 3
on pousse le pion
et au final la kaki a réussi un petit
peu à se reconstruire une sorte de
cabane
voyez avec le pion high c'est caché
derrière le pion et la fourchette qui
arrive et qui met you en PLS
ça va être
catastrophe d'un G3 tours géant il y a
tout qui va tomber et ça va être ça va
être perdu je pense pour pour nous dans
cette partie
et c'est abandon c'est
es la partie désolé
mais la partie numéro 20 Naka qui a des
Noirs cette fois-ci
qui bouge que des pions alors j'ai pas
vu il bouge tous ses pions là il fait
n'importe quoi
à 4 il sort pas ses pièces
il faut punir
il faut le punir
non il est imprenable en vrai c'est
extrêmement dur plus ça va vite plus il
est fort
c'est vraiment pour ça en fait que
[Musique]
que
ces matchs sont quand même déséquilibrés
après c'est le 8e de finale
c'est normal que
que
gagne ses matchs assez facile
c'est normal
en plus you plus ça joue plus la main
en face il joue de manière très bizarre
et il arrive pas à le punir et ça peut
être extrêmement frustrant de jouer un
joueur comme ça qui joue de manière à
vraiment
trop marginal quoi
c'est 5 il joue hyper vite regardez il
est encore 50 secondes à la pendule avec
les Noirs là j'ai 28 coups il a dépensé
que 8 secondes
et en même temps il jouit il parle
il danse fait tout ce qu'il veut
nous avons que pour lui les trouve
facile
bruit à simplicité pour un genre comme
ça tu as l'impression que
[Musique]
que c'est trop facile
F3 s'il prend live manger des trois il
veut se venger sur le cavalier en
Détroit ici
et
qui réfléchit pour la première fois de
la partie curieux il a pris F3 qui est
une faute ou Naka qui
a qui a pris move je crois qu'il a pris
move d'en prendre des trois il pensait
qu'il allait faire d'un point il a pris
Moussa et
ça en vrai c'est bien fait c'est bien
fait dans le sens où n'a qu'à est
tellement en train de troll qu'à un
moment
le troller trolley et G4 qui est parti
tout à l'heure on m'a demandé si si j'ai
quatre un être joué dans la dans le
dans le dans le tournoi et dans la
réponse est oui j'ai 4
et je vais
car F3
et là c'est un peu horrible ce que fait
en plus maca parce qu'il a joué A3
premier coup puis il joue A4 dans
l'autre partie puis là je vais B4 puis
B3 puis C4 C3 plus de 4 de 3 puis E4 E3
puis F4 R3 et là j'ai 4 en fait Naka il
joue tous les coups de pions
possibles pour commencer la première
échec après il va jouer H4 dans les
parties avec les Blancs il est pas du
tout sérieux dans ce match il est pas
sérieux quand c'est parti
il est tout le temps mal parce qu'il
fait des ouvertures catastrophiques mais
après est tellement fort que malgré tout
you n'arrive pas à faire la différence
qu'avec G3
la jauge qui bug souvent là il perd la
tour
intéressant
et qu'elle va les prendre en l'air ça a
l'air quand même vraiment pas mal et la
cabane dépendra H3 raté par par maca et
là c'est une pièce de moins écouter Yuki
va encore gagner cette partie
ça a l'air perdant complet il y a une
pièce de plus attention il sort plus
il va rendre le pion mais il va manger
le 4
en contre-jour et qui perd tous ses
points
mais le cavalier il est encore enfermé
hein en pratique c'est toujours pas
clair il faut le finir ce n'est qu'un
il faut le finir on va sacrifier la
qualité
comment est-ce que je joue ton rap
qui ressort cette cavalu E4 plutôt
réduite à des prises faut bouger le fou
pour sortir le roi ou je baississe je le
rends en B7
est-ce que foi peut-être
un cas il se fait un peu un peu mal
traité là dans cette section de jeu pour
l'instant
c'est pas une partie en prix nous vend
cette partie c'est pris un cavalier je
crois en fait il veut tellement jouer
vite
qui qui joue pas bien vous voyez il a 40
secondes à la pendule après 40 coups
après c'est pas encore fini il a pas
encore perdu
ici ok mais attention à encore ce pion
encore le plus rural ça va être abandon
et Yuki gagne cette partie et qui prend
l'avantage dans ce troisième set
le score il est encore de 13,8 quand
même il y a encore un très gros avantage
pour un gars c'est absolument impossible
de de perdre ce match à ce niveau là il
y a tellement d'avance
imaginez il y a cinq parties différentes
en 20 minutes c'est limite si moi je
joue je perdais pas ce match je crois
limite je pense que je parlerai quand
même mais bon 20 minutes
cinq parties une plus une heure
je pense que je perds quand même ce
match
mais c'est pas si clair parce qu'il y a
pas beaucoup de temps en fait
mais lui n'a qu'à Naka quoi c'est pas
tout
E5 a été joué encore une fois il joue il
joue à une vitesse la casse c'est
affolant
dame de
je pense qu'il est juste sérieux les
étudiants dans le match
tout simplement
tout refusé
[Musique]
à trois
erreurs qui sont jouées mais bon
extrêmement compliqué ambulette
[Musique]
en Bullet
toi vous dire grand chose par contre
pour déstabiliser un petit peu ce centre
de pions
va arriver
[Musique]
et ça va être abandon
pas encore abandon mais ça va être perdu
la possibilité
c'est juste horrible puis on prend un
cavalier H4
c'est horrible
et maintenant
elle est partie suivante
allez de 2 dans ce match de Bullet je
crois que j'avais mis deux et plus il me
semble
j'avais mis je crois en prédiction
je vais vérifier j'avais mis
[Musique]
j'avais mis deux et moins
et plus de 2 il y avait 57%
ce qui veut dire que pour l'instant
il y a encore une nulle à faire pour
pour terminer cette prédiction
juste une nul pour
la fin 17 minutes pour ne pas perdre une
partie
on a qu'un en Bullet c'est juste quelque
chose
ce qu'il a fait là c'était quoi
premier coup c'était G3 ok j'annonce que
le prochain coup blanc de Naka ça va
être H4 ou H3
mais quelqu'un qui ajoute absolument
tous les cours elle commence par A3 puis
à 4 B3 ub4 C3 il a fait tous les coups
de pions un par un et là il en est un H3
non il en a deux trois là premier coup
donc prochain coup ça va être ça
puissant c'est vraiment un maxi troll
franchement maca
il est vraiment pas sérieux il rend trop
fou ses adversaires à faire n'importe
quoi dans les ouvertures en plus il les
vagues quoi en vrai ça peut trop trop
rendre fou
j'ai plein de choses qui arrivent je
prends un 4 pour le matos
ça m'étonne pas de NACA il aime bien
prendre le matériel
5 dame là ça fait peur quand même aussi
hein en prison qui n'a pas été mangé
hein OK
comme quoi les joueurs
même NACA oublie des pièces en prises
non mais chaque fois
attention à pas trop se faire
raté à parnaka tactiquement à la fin
d'un cas il commence un peu à fatiguer
j'ai l'impression parce que là
franchement on le Bullet et ben
tant que Bullet
you il est quand même pas mal hein pour
l'instant
les F5 a été heureux ça va être Matt
très bientôt avec G4
tous les plans qui avancent de Tours
il faut encore il faut encore terminer
mais prise tout droit apparemment j'ai
trois faisait nulle ordinateur encore
une fois c'est c'est un calcul
incompréhensible
et avec les Blancs il va jouer la nuit
là sécuriser
et you qui joue la gagne absolument
voilà la raison là il faut faire la
gamme quand même un tape depuis on va
passer ici il faut y aller mais en fait
c'est pas si clair au final les pions
qui vont quand même aller assez vite et
puis on blanc
30 secondes d'avance angulaire c'est
incroyable c'est incroyable tu as un
Bullet en plus il joue tellement vite
qu'il arrive pas à laisser le temps à
you de
de faire des primovs quoi c'est horrible
il n'a pas le temps c'est trop dur
c'est trop dur
il va le matin je pense qu'il va mettre
beaucoup de temps à mater pour trouver
comme d'hab en fait il faudrait que you
abandonne mais il le fera peut-être pas
et je pense vraiment que
Naka ok je pensais qu'il allait perdre
du temps pour le matin exprès
allez hop
donc 3 2
un jeune je me rends compte je suis
désolé un jeune me rendre compte que
pendant toute la partie d'avant je
pensais que Naka avait gagné la partie
je suis tombé de couleur tellement je
suis à fond dans et
en fait non hyper 3 2 donc là du coup je
peux même finir la prédiction
je vais vous la finir la traduction et
parce que il a rêvé clairement à plus de
deux hop
et salut à toi Nordahl
alors H3
x 4 il reste combien de temps il reste
13 minutes dans ce match avec un score
de 14 à 9
après je pense franchement que malgré
tout
pour le match est vraiment très dur
[Musique]
même quand il joue mal et ben il joue
mal mais il joue bien
et tactiquement il rate très rarement
des choses
d'abord j'ai du Fou
pour pas se prendre pour reprendre et
dans mes échelle dans notre C8
c'est
un peu passé à qui va courir tour à 8 le
pion qui avance Tam à 5 peut-être
rentrer la dame quelque part
[Musique]
trois trous en Bullet
il reste 11 minutes à la pendule
je crois qu'on a pas joué une seule
ouverture normale dans ce match
il est un jeu une fois une vraie
ouverture
ça
c'est 3 donc
je pense
je pense qu'il va balancé des pions B4
C4
un truc comme ça avec petit rock
peut-être
sur
la case des cadres un jour cavalier F1 a
été joué
donc ici un peu le G3 H4 sur sur G4 Dame
des 7 attention option orange 3
donc c'est risqué de prendre ce pion
mais
il faut calculer puis on prend
toutes les cases mais bon il empêche en
tout cas le coup H4 qui était difficile
aussi apparaît
encore une fois Naka qui joue
extrêmement vite qui fait des menaces
même si tu aimes la spidon et ben ça
fait
peur ça fait réfléchir et extrêmement
Marlo maca complètement horrible en fait
prise d'un point h4g1
[Musique]
mais je vois pas trop je peux jouer
autre chose ah non il y aura tout refuge
à la fin un truc comme ça
[Musique]
ça
a été raté par l'autre jour aussi fois
si c'est un dessin ouais c'est le
bulletin les joueurs sont en fin de
match les gens sont fatigués font un peu
n'importe quoi et des pièces en prise
dans tous les sens
dans la scène
et gros craquage quand même à ce niveau
là
même ça montre un petit peu à quel point
le match il est intense
ça rate des pièces en Inde de partout
on dirait que c'est moi qui joue
OK
incroyable incroyable qui gagne autant
on arrive en oubliant en fait à la fin
[Musique]
elle est quatre heures dans cette bulle
qui reste 7 minutes
il faut que j'ai 4
et apprendre gagner 7 il va gentil
bizarre où les coups c'est 6 et à 5
c'est les coûts qui sont assez utiles au
final
tout racisme probablement
essayer de balancer F5 dès que possible
l'adversaire
prise Dame des deux peut-être
le cavalier et on va OK
les pièces
mais regardez on a joué on a joué à 24
coups il a encore une minute à la
pendule
c'est horrible il joue trop vite il est
trop la pression il fait zéro faute
et pour dame j'ai 5 aussi peut-être ça
dépend son numéro
mais il est vraiment pour F5 du coup et
F5 tu manges de quoi tu manges de la
Tour Eiffel
que c'est aussi un coup plus tard d'un
prend puis on prend une casse en
Cavaillon E5
cavalage 7
garder à 50 secondes contre 15 joue trop
vite
ça tourne même
si on prend et rentrer avec les pièces
d'apprendre la tour
et ce fou hein
et la mauvaise pièce des blancs
n'ont plus de mauvaise pièce enfin les
cavaliers ici c'est pas de mauvaises
pièces
qui vont se recycler qui un jour seront
OK
mais ce fou ici est quand même vraiment
pas très beau attention F7
alors
qui est revenu défendre ici elle tourne
avec mes pièces
je vais aller
en G6 probablement pour mon CF4
le fou qui vient ici empêcher cavalier à
cavaliers
qui est
attention la jauge qui n'était pas pour
au début
j'attaquais le pion à 6 et je vais
pousser les pions j'ai quand même quatre
pions passés liés contre 200 les ailes
qui va gagner
les pions passés éloigner ou les quatre
pions centraux c'est c'est assez
compliqué cette finale en pratique c'est
tellement dur pour les blancs encore
rien à faire
un traitable dans ce match
un traitable à la plus que 3 minutes 50
et laquelle qui joue enfin une ouverture
normale enfin il fallait arriver jusqu'à
la 27e partie pour voir une vraie
ouverture une catalane avec les Blancs
pourtant il est pas en danger dans le
match je crois qu'il y en a marre de
troll
H4 H5 H6
c'est le phase 0 qui a un tout ce genre
de coup avec H4 H5 dans quasiment toutes
les parties
E4
quand même
sur le pion E4 dans
[Musique]
la perte de foot plateforme très très
forte
on prend et la donnée la qualité qu'elle
va les prendre la dame pour en sortir tu
prendras ici il y aura après mes cinq à
la fin en terme B6
obligatoire je peux manger ici pour
reprendre
pas mal pour le noir
ça a été joué tu as du coup
comme C6 encore mieux qui empêche ça
parce qu'il y aura d'un point ici à
chaque
dame 2 je défends
est-ce qu'un coup comme tout ressens
essayer de faire un truc
les chances de dames jouer à leur tour
au sein que j'aime bien moi il y aura
toujours dans ma vie
qui est tombé chez you qui a fait un peu
la tête quand il a perdu le pion
et ouais
Yuki complètement à l'ouest là
il y en a marre
en vrai c'est dur c'est dur hein quand
je contrôle comme ça qui
qui a une le match est long
le match est trop trop long quoi
ça se finit jamais
donc ça c'est souvent la dernière partie
du match il reste une minute au timer
je pense à se terminer sur cette partie
là
à traiter jouer
il y en a qui fait un peu les oreilles
d'annonce on appelle ça comme ça
les oreilles d'ânes
si tu l'écoutes pas à fond bah oui ils
sont fous ça c'est un ça c'était
vraiment un match pour lui c'est une
formalité
avec les Blancs il joue A4 avec les
Noirs il joue A5 tout le match comme ça
bien sûr qu'il est pas à fond
il y en a rien à
là il fait son petit show sur
en stream mais en vrai
comme de la c'est un match pour lui
assez facile et c'est qui va gagner et
du coup il fait son petit spectacle mais
il s'en fout complètement
[Musique]
et maintenant en fait peu importe qu'il
a il a toujours à la pendule
plus de 20 à 30 secondes en 8 lettres
peu importe la boss qu'il a
joue pas bien mais ils sont fous
je sais pas ce qu'on peut faire avec les
noirs
à faire avec les Noirs dame J7 il va
faire ou demain
un tour en prison
3 4 il va voir il va revenir comme ça
j'aime bien quand avec la magie ça a
l'air pas mal
il faut ramener les pièces un peu
et c'est bien dans la partie du match le
Timer est arrivé à zéro
et ça va se terminer
là dessus ta machine
[Musique]
on se place
un peu un peu risqué et tout en prison
il faut essayer de
F3 peut-être le Caval qui peut revenir
en E5
une belle opération ça serait d'échanger
[Musique]
un petit peu à voler en éclat la dame
qui a un temps fermé en h6
il donne tout et Yuki qui en plus il y
en a vraiment vraiment marre je pense
dans ce match
B3 il y a deux qui tombent
assez dur un match que tu souffres comme
ça pendant tout le tout le match c'est
juste impossible impossible
psychologiquement c'est
ça rend fou donc là 19 score final du
match 5,5
+ 1 si c'est le micro et demi en 3 + 1
et 7 3 en une plus une donc demain je
sais plus ce qui est avec un match je
peux vous le redire très très rapidement
j'ai la photo ici là sur mon téléphone
demain on va avoir le match Wesley
contre aronia je sais pas si il est
Cécile il est il est couvert c'est même
moi qui le couvre je suis bête donc
demain je vais mettre la je vais mettre
la cam demain à partir de deux 20h et
ben je vais être encore en direct pour
le match du coup saut contre à rognan ça
marche qui va être je pense beaucoup
plus
beaucoup plus Close en termes de match
celui-là à 19.9 quand il est vraiment
injouable mais en tout cas merci à tous
d'avoir suivi de stream et je vous dis
bah à demain pour de nouvelles aventures
et bon lundi soir à tous